That's what a professional does.
Professional turns that bitch down down.
Huh?
A nonprofessional or someone who's half
ass in it.
They keep that phone up.
Really?
Yeah.
Have you seen that?
Some people keep that phone up,
that check that phone on time.
They'll check in the middle of podcasts.
Russell.
Peter can't leave his phone alone to
really try again through a fucking whole
podcast with Russell Peters without
checking his tweets.
What?
Impossible.
He's checking things.
Some days you read off tweets and say,
oh people.
Oh Doug Benson used to do that.
That's why.
Can't read off the tweets.
I'm trying to get away from it.
If I can't,
I'll find times if I'm going to go eat
now,
I'll leave it in my phone,
in the car.
Power move and hadn't done that before.
I just started and it's not even a
natural choice I'm making almost.
It's like something I need to do.
Yeah.
To chicken shit.
Move scared.
Scared to leave it in there.
Yeah.
Scared.
Lead that foam would have some
important.
I asked if I needed to know,
but there isn't.
There is a thing like what if something
important happens?
Yeah,
but what do you think like when does
that happen?
Super Rare.
But if it did happen where your phone
was in the car and somebody needed you,
you'd feel terrible.
Right.
But you can just.
What is the,
what's the balance?
It's so slippery when we didn't have any
way to get in touch with back in the
day.
You have to yell for help.
Remember that?
Yeah.
You can't yell how?
Not in Los Angeles.
There's too many people.
You yell for help.
Nobody's in some languages helped mean
something else.
I think it's,
you know,
something not good at or something in
Arabic or something.
People will fuck you up.
You just make that up.
I'm not sure.
Honestly,
I think I might've heard that because I
live in Westwood and we have a very
diverse over there.
There's a lot of people sometimes
yelling stuff in the street.
Do you think a for real do you think
help mean something bad in other
languages?
So real.
Somebody told me hello means go to hell
in like Greek or Latin,
like,
um,
like politics means like a political,
like,
uh,
like um,
something like not good,
like something tick,
like a tick,
like blood sucking.
Oh really?
The government or something like that.
Let's start with one.
Let's start with,
uh,
should we do it with hello first?
Yeah,
I think because,
and I just say things and I don't even
know sometimes think somebody just told
me to say hello when I was young and
I've been saying in my whole life,
but what does help mean is helping
anything in another language is help a
bad word and other languages.
So I'm looking up if the word help means
something in another language.
Not that there weren't help.
If the word help means something in
another language that
you're gonna have to award it.
You're gonna have to word it uniquely I
think because it's a.
that's a hard one.
That's a,
that's a,
that's yeah.
I don't even know anymore.
Now it's translation.
Something like that.
Maybe an Arabic or something.
I'm not.
I that have any sort of alternate
meanings and other languages.
He,
I'm not accusing anybody the Arab
nations or whatever,
or a beach or whatever,
you know,
the Arabic and Hebrew,
like those old old languages have the
coolest letters.
Like the way they write things,
like you look at some old Hindu script
or something like that.
Like why is that looks so cool.
It seemed like a mystery man.
Anytime,
like even Russian when you see Russia
and written out and you're like,
whoa,
look at the crazy little letters they
have.
Like,
look at that.
Like this is like some alien writing.
Yeah,
I'd be furious.
I'm like,
I couldn't,
I couldn't imagine having to learn some
of the other languages.
You know,
like I'm going to China next week we
want to Shanghai and I'm like,
it's basically just gonna be looking
around at different drawings,
you know,
like as far as even though words go,
it's going to be.
I think they have a lot of stuff in
English there.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Are a lot.
A lot of countries where there's a lot
of tourism.
They just put stuff in English.
English seems to be the language that
most European countries,
like most people know you can,
you can kind of get by and in Italy you
can kind of get by in Germany,
just speak English.
It's a,
it's,
it's really interesting man,
because it's because I guess there's so
much tourism and I guess everyone's
worried about us because we have the
nuclear bombs.
Everybody learned English and we
traveled a lot because we have more
money here probably.
So we have the ability to go places
maybe.
Um,
do you like English?
That's the only language I know.
So yeah,
I like it,
but it's just weird how much cooler
other languages look when they're
written out.
I guess it's just because we're what
we're accustomed to,
but like tie at writing or like I was
sweating.
I tried to read something one time and
tie.
I was sweating by the end of the
craziest.
I mean ic food.
Yeah.
Like it just,
like,
it took me out of my element,
man.
There was a couple of,
uh,
a couple of words off,
you know,
I almost needed help Asian characters
look like if you had a movie like a
science fiction movie and in the movie
they found a crashed Ufo and it had some
writing on the I beams or something like
that.
It would look like a lot of Asian
writing.
Right.
It would look like something,
something crazy from Asia that like,
you're like,
what am I looking at?
Right.
Like alien issue.
You're saying I might as well be alien
writing if you don't know it.
Yeah.
If there were alien writing,
you think it's going to look more like
something from Asian writing than it is
from American writing.
Well,
it'd be weird if it was like comic book
font.
Yeah,
like a or whatever.
It's like,
wait a minute.
Alien speak English.
Yeah,
Bro.
Everybody does.
What if aliens were in like a Boeing
shuttle man?
That's the biggest mind fuck that I ever
heard was that because of the size of
infinity [inaudible] not only is there
another theo vaughn out there in the
world,
but because infinity is so big,
I'm going to butcher for short.
We talked about this a little bit less.
I was in.
He did.
We did a little thing you've ever done.
Someone has done the exact same things,
the exact same order down to the last
millisecond.
Do you believe?
Do you.
Okay.
So that's something that you think are,
that's something that you think that
could be really true.
I think it could be really true.
Um,
but honestly my brain is not really
strong enough to compute that,
so I would have to take many,
many,
many hours to really thinking about what
that means because right now when I'm
saying what I'm saying,
I'm like,
it's one of those whoa dude.
Things like I'm saying it,
but I'm not really thinking it through.
Yeah.
I.
How much,
how much are you really thinking
through?
Yeah,
just a couple of steps.
You're not really thinking.
Okay.
That there's a.
So then that means for you,
there's another,
there's another man out there who did
comedy it last night at the comedy store
who wore,
did the exact same set,
tripped over the exact same words,
spelt his water the same way every.
It's supposed to be everything and not.
Not only that,
but because infinity so big.
They're supposed to be an infinite
number of those people out there.
Yeah.
I don't want that.
I don't man,
because that would hurt my feelings.
Honestly.
It would make me feel.
I think it makes accept.
I think it makes sense.
I think the universe is so big,
right?
I mean,
everything's so big.
Just what we know about our solar system
so big.
It's so big.
That alone,
it's crazy.
The idea that there's no end to the
crazy.
We're like,
Nah,
it's gotta be an end.
No,
no,
no.
That's too crazy.
Like what's too crazy when it comes to
the universe,
the universe is crazy.
There is nothing about it that makes any
sense.
It's so crazy that we don't like to
think about it.
Last night I was watching the fireworks
and the fireworks were going off and I
was thinking,
yeah,
this is Kinda cool.
You know what's cooler?
The fucking billions of flying
explosions that are above our heads,
the fireworks that are constantly in the
sky.
It's like we just,
we'll get together for like some
something made in Honduras,
but the fact that they're like shooting
stars every night and nobody gives a
fuck.
Yeah.
And we like because the streetlights,
we don't see the craziest light show
ever,
which is the Milky Way.
Yeah.
You know,
when you draw,
make that drive out to vegas or you
know,
into driving through Montana at night or
something like that.
You pull over.
What does that.
Is that fireworks from last night by
last night?
Just from a,
the NBC for helicopter Pasedena to
downtown.
That's awesome.
Those are illegal.
At least half of them are illegal.
Right.
I would say most of them are illegal.
It looks like a lot of like a kind of
civil war artwork also sped up dude for
a firefighter,
that has got to be a crazy time,
but some of them get off.
I think on fires,
like some of them,
I think they want a little bit of fire.
You don't think?
Yes.
Well,
it's been proven that some people that
are mentally ill that become firemen and
actually start fires something,
you know,
it's not,
it's not 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent of them or whatever the
number is,
but occasionally in every line of work,
you know,
you get someone who's crazy.
Yeah.
And I could see that dude,
you want something gone and you don't
have a lot of money or anything like
that.
I think of that.
It's also just that they're crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
they're just.
Some people there's something wrong,
right.
There's,
there's connections that are being made
in there and then not they,
they,
they're capable of doing things just to
deceive.
People would rip people off or they're
capable of doing things for their own
personal gain,
like lighting a building on fire just so
they could put it out.
Like there's some people that are just
broken,
like there's something about them that's
just not connected.
Right?
Yeah.
We should shut them down,
man.
I think.
I think in the future we have to have
some better programs to find out who's
just not even who doesn't care about
people.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's people that don't care about
people who doesn't care about people
because if you don't care about people
then it's just not.
Then you shouldn't be here.
He should be somewhere else.
You should be in a place where they
don't have any people,
you know?
Yeah.
It's just a dangerous thing to have
around.
For the most part.
It's fine.
Right?
Because life is fairly easy and
civilized times.
Right?
Most of this stuff is fun.
Most of the stuff without,
you know,
the caveat for the occasional chaos,
but it's just fucking.
It's hard to tell how crazy people are
until something really happens and me
and you really need to count on them and
when they,
you know,
when you're pinned underneath the
dresser and they look at you and they
just run out of the room and just take
off,
you know,
like,
you're not even going to help me.
Wow.
There's people like that.
Do you think some of those people didn't
even know that they would?
Do that until the situation arises that
that's sometimes what I would love to
have some and I know this sounds a
little dark but like to have some
serious stressors in our world to find
out even who I really am,
you know,
like to see who rises to like who you
are inside,
like what rises to the core of my skin
and says this is who I am.
You know,
like I got trapped in an elevator,
wants to do with like seven or eight
people.
Okay.
And this sounds like a small idea,
but this was like three hours,
right.
And suddenly like at first one dude's
kind of verbose.
He's suddenly like I'm the leader,
but like an hour later he's like trying
to fuck a couple chicks that are also
stuck in the elevator and you start to
see like,
okay wait,
when he was trying to fuck them,
like it was hitting on them or he's
trying to actually get down in the
elevator.
No,
he wasn't kind to fucking other,
but he was maybe going to fuck them
later if they got out of the elevator a
safely,
not like a rape or like a guy who's
going gonna date them or take them to
dinner and then hopefully have sex with
them at some point if they want to as
well.
But he um,
but you know what I'm saying?
So yeah,
consensual sex.
Yeah,
yeah,
there you go.
But he,
but you started to see who was who,
like one guy was like,
just literally wouldn't listen.
Anyone tried to rip the doors open for
two hours and then like just like,
just like gave up on that one lady was
really scared.
Like immediately it started to kind of
fold out who was going to be who,
you know,
I wouldn't know what to do.
I don't know if I don't think you're
supposed to climb out though.
That seems like
death,
right?
Climb out into that shaft.
You're supposed to stay here as far as I
know you're supposed to stay.
I mean,
they must have some sort of regular,
but you know,
have an elevator fell in one of the UFC
hotels like real far and fucked up CB
dollar away.
One of the UFC fighters.
His back is fucked up from that.
Apparently.
Apparently he's suing.
I don't think he fought that day.
I think they had to cancel his fight.
I think I might be wrong about that,
but I know his back was like
significantly fucked up from that fall.
Elevators make it too easy,
man.
I miss the old days sometimes when you
do this for the fight.
He scratched from the fight.
Yeah.
And he's fought since,
but I think he's still having problems
with his back.
Yeah.
And yeah,
it's hard to fix,
to have back to one of the hardest.
One of the hardest things to make better
again.
It seems like every time people get
surgery,
it's just a slippery slope.
It's very rare that someone gets surgery
on their back and they go,
oh,
my back's great now.
Everything's fine.
It's always like,
yeah,
I got to go in again.
I got another disk.
You're like,
oh no.
And they're literally getting their back
fused from top to bottom.
No dudes with like four or five fake
disks in their back that are still
fighters to Yo know.
Hey,
tito has several fused in his neck.
He has artificial spacers from where the
discs used to be.
He has that in his back,
his multiple operations on his back.
Do you think that that like,
because some people think like you know,
a lot of your ci and you're like line up
as in,
you know,
like you're.
Do you think that that catchall tourney
of it?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's real.
What is that?
Is it,
is it the actual disk gelatin or as the
spine itself?
The spinal column.
We're all the.
All the nerves are firing all the way up
to the brainstem.
Yeah.
It's really fucking crazy thing to risk.
If you think about that,
like the connection between your brain
and then that cord that goes to all your
body and everything moving and it's all
just this back area that very few people
ever even exercise,
which is so crazy.
Everybody's doing all this shit to get
your biceps looking fly and pump your
tits up and very few people are
concentrating on like lower back
exercises.
Reverse hypers,
protecting your spine,
putting muscle all around that bitch.
Work that core.
Do like kettle bell windmills.
You ever do?
Kettlebell windmills do?
Oh Shit,
they're so good.
Kettlebell windmills,
you.
You press the kettle button.
You go down and touch your touch the
ground by your foot and then
straightened back up again.
It's just amazing for your spine,
like all the muscles around your back
that stabilize everything and your
obliques and your abs and all your core.
It's a great exercise.
I've got to do more like adult fitness,
man.
I got to Gel a little bit.
You're.
That's what it looks
like.
Damn.
Look at all that shit.
That's the human spine.
Yup.
That's the nervous system.
That's the nervous feel like I'm an eat
this in China next week.
Dude.
In a weird way you can have dick over
there.
Somebody said they can.
You're gonna have human.
A human.
Indeck of mine said that,
and he's eating a lot of how he's eating
everywhere.
Is He Andrew Zimmerman,
honored foods guy now the podcast?
Yeah.
He's a chef.
He travels all over the world.
Really?
Cool guy.
Welcome this.
That picture is fucking bizarre,
man.
To think that that's all the stuff
that's firing your nerves.
That's crazy.
And what does that.
What does that even look like?
It almost looks like a jelly fish or
like a.
It looks like it's reaching for
something doesn't.
Yeah.
Shooting off into the cosmos son thing
at the top is making nuclear bombs at
the top is making four g cell phones and
40 megapixel front facing cameras.
It's Megan.
That thing is megan time machines.
That fucking thing is making satellite
transmission of video signals and
simultaneously delivered to televisions
worldwide.
That's what that thing is making,
dude.
You're things making Tesla's robberies,
pigs making pistols and steroids.
That things make it oxycotton that
fucking things make it everything.
That's what's fucked up about the human
breast.
Scary is that when you think about that
things making whiskey,
that things were making crack crystal
meth or crank
things,
making nail Polish and fake tits,
that thing is off the chain.
If you look at,
if you looked at the human brain for
like all this shit that is responsible
for you,
Blake,
what?
That area.
Oh my God,
and it looks like something you would
think maybe wouldn't even do nothing to.
You walk by that on the street and you
didn't know it was a brain.
You'd be like,
oh man.
She asked.
One of my favorite out here.
You was kind of a game is Mars attacks
where they have.
They're exposed brain.
Remember that you don't remember Mars
attacks.
I never seen anything like that.
Never saw Mars attacks.
I don't watch all of
this is one of the greatest movies of
all time.
It's Tim Burton,
right?
Is that who I believe it's because I'll
watch something amazing.
It's so good.
Dude.
Jack Nicholson is in it and he pleased,
pleased to obviously different people
really,
but it's obviously the same guy playing
to people and it's never brought up so
it's a great movie man.
I mean it is a great,
great movie.
Oh,
it looks bad dude.
It's so good.
Is it really?
It seems like it looks bad because
you're watching here,
but it's all on purpose.
It's on purpose.
It's like when the,
when this is what it is,
is they somehow or another captured how
we feel about this time period.
They captured it with this weird like
Vegas thing with this is the president
back then and when these aliens come off
this spaceship,
it's,
there's something about the way they
moved to makes you think like you're
watching a movie from the fifties but
still good,
like just
good enough.
But what he did by making the effects
weird and barely real is he almost gave
you in this stallion for like 19
sixties,
19 seventies movie.
You can see that a little bit right
here.
Yeah.
But.
But it's better.
It's way better than anything they were
capable of.
I mean,
look at the fucking,
the shadows and the head and everything
like that.
Watched a little bit of this real quick.
This is when they first land
come
in.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's cool.
Do you think you'd eat something from
Mars?
If they had,
like,
if they had to say this because I knew
you'd like to be a wild eater.
I've seen some of the stuff you eat.
You eat kind of rare.
You know,
you,
you know you're not,
you're not afraid to eat the rayer.
And would you have,
um,
say this,
they catch a,
a Mars donkey or something,
you know,
and they just,
they're serving up.
You don't even know what's in it.
Bright Eyes Wide Shut party serving up a
donkey from Mars,
right?
How many pounds of that?
But you can add the.
I would need it.
No chance.
First of all,
people were.
people are going to be definitely mad at
you.
You think people are mad at you for
eating animals on earth.
Imagine eating animals from space.
Only one.
Don't be so fucking mad at you.
Second of all,
I would want,
I would not want to be an early adopter
of Mars meet.
Really don't want to sit back.
Look this,
people that are convinced that meat,
I don't agree with them,
but there's people that are convinced
that meat is bad for you.
That meat itself is bad for you.
Yeah,
because a lot of people that eat meat
wind up with a bunch of heart disease.
The problem is that they're not really
measuring just the meat.
They're just measuring people that eat
meat.
What else do you eat?
You eat a lot of sugar.
You have a lot of bread,
you have a lot of pasta.
You eat a lot of this and you drain
Tony's.
Yeah,
you might have.
You might smoke cigarettes,
so it's hard to tell and I think
different things are good for different
people,
but people can't even agree on whether
or not it's healthy to eat meat.
There's some people that disagree in it,
right?
What's.
Wouldn't you want to wait to see what
Mars meet to people?
Wouldn't you want to fucking I,
I'd want to sit back and be like,
dude,
I'm good with Bison.
You can eat those Mars donkeys all day
long.
I'm going to see what a 20 year profiled
fucking donkeys from Mars eaters looks
like.
A little bit of star dust steak or
something at a Mars.
They only have one,
but I'm saying that one donkey.
Yeah,
but it could be like some preannounce
getting your system and you got mad cow
disease like blindly.
You could also.
What if you adopt a superpower by eating
it?
That's true.
That's one thing that nobody ever brings
up with nuclear energy,
like all this,
all these nuclear disasters,
everybody's terrified of mutations
and radioactive waves and all this
shit's going to fuck us up,
but nobody remembers comic books where
every single time somebody got hit with
some radioactive shit,
they became a superhero superhero.
That's never happened here.
I wonder if I could handle the dude if I
had a super.
I just feel like I would tell everyone
it wouldn't be able to keep it a secret.
Some secrets powers.
You're allowed to just tell everybody.
Some dudes,
they just tell everybody,
right?
Like who?
Who doesn't have to keep it a secret.
Obviously the thing he can't keep it a
secret.
What is it that the big x men,
they had to go?
Yeah,
but they had high,
but the thing doesn't hide.
The thing is just,
that's what he's covered in rocks,
you know?
Say.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
But the big fists.
Yeah.
Giant club time.
Who else doesn't have to hide anything?
You can hide anything.
Bruce Bannister,
who,
who's,
who is personable banner.
Bruce Banner.
Do you know when they show as a
carpenter?
Isn't he?
No.
Do you know that when they did the
incredible health TV show,
they changed his name from Bruce to
David because people thought Bruce was
gay.
Really was a lot of bruises.
Ged then do.
That's always been the stereotypical
name.
Oh wait,
when like a comedian would do a hack
joke about a gay guy,
they'd be like,
birth me randy over.
And really I would never heard Randy,
but bruce,
it's always been bruce is the name that
they would use.
So apparently people in the seventies
when the hulk TV show was around with
Lou Ferrigno.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They just decided like,
Hey,
let's,
uh,
let's change this name,
change it,
make it David David Banner and we all
comic book Dorks like me.
We're like,
what?
How dare you,
how dare you change his name?
That was the best show ever because it
made it feel like a,
it may.
If,
if you were ugly,
you can still be cool and do neat stuff.
I felt like,
well it was the revenge of people who
are bullied and picked on.
There's the idea that you could be this
nerdy guy and you get picked on by these
assholes and you just fucking hulk out
become bulletproof.
Yeah.
I met him at the post office one time.
The frig.
No,
I met him.
He's a real nice guy.
Yeah.
He seemed nice.
He was with a lady friend and it might
have been his wife a thing.
He's still yoked as fuck.
He's jacked like,
you know,
um,
he looks really good.
Like you looks healthy too.
It's crazy.
I mean,
the dude's got to be deep into his
sixties,
but he looks very healthy.
He might wonder who,
who,
who.
Um,
I wonder if people are going to start
living for like a really like looking at
them there.
That dude looks healthy as fuck and now
they are.
He looks a little bit more,
more reasonable.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
he was a gigantic supersized human at
one point in time.
That's what he used to look like.
What the fuck is that?
So big.
So when you saw him on the hulk,
the problem was he couldn't really be
that defined for long periods of time
and film a show because it
was too unhealthy.
Oh,
it's super unhealthy when those guys are
like right about to pose down when
they're about to.
They're on death's door.
They are really unhealthy.
They get lightheaded.
Look at that dude.
Oldest fuck.
Who is that old and jacked?
That Willie Nelson.
That looks like a 75 year old jack man.
See them.
They have those,
that row say that guy gets shot and
killed.
Dude.
Depends how far I am from civilization.
Okay.
Let's say you're far man.
Eat them.
Yeah,
I'd eat them if it was,
whether or not eating them or not
surviving,
getting home to my family or something
like that.
Say this,
then I'm going to put you under a little
bit of,
um,
uh,
some,
if you don't mind.
Is that okay?
Do it.
Please do.
Okay.
So a ship went down a shuttle and air
ship or something,
a plane.
And you know,
like that movie alive,
right?
You're out there.
Do you?
Are you the chef?
You know you're going to eat it.
You know you're going to eat well.
It's whether or not the bodies like the
people are killed already.
The real problem is when people start
killing people and meeting people,
then you've got a real problem.
Okay?
People are already killed.
People are already dead.
It's to senior citizens.
That's it.
It was a small plane.
Well,
you got to decide.
People can live without food for several
weeks,
especially if you're the average
American.
You've got a lot of fat in your body.
After a day or so,
your body kicks into fat burning ketosis
mode,
but you're going to be hungry though.
You're going to be hungry,
but you will be less hungry believe it
or not.
After the first day,
once your body kicks into fat burning,
like have you ever been on a fat burning
diet?
I've just on Paleo for a month.
It's a little different because Paleo,
you're still eating a lot of
carbohydrates.
Just cutting out all the grains and
things like that.
When you go on a fat burning diet,
one of the first things that happens is
your appetite just changes radically.
It's really weird.
Like you just stopped being hungry the
same way,
like hunger isn't a desperation thing.
Like when I know when I'm not ketogenic
because then my hunger gets desperate,
like I have to eat something.
Like I feel like,
Ooh,
I never feel like that.
With Quito it's like I'm hungry,
but I'm,
I'm okay.
It's like and through the day,
like energy levels are much more
stabilized.
That's what I felt like on Paleo.
I'd never done anything like that.
I mean,
I lost like 11 pounds was telling them
think I was supposed to lose,
like I didn't really have like a plan or
anything,
but next thing you know,
like I felt,
I never felt like I had to eat.
I felt like I needed to eat to get to
the next few moments in my life,
but I didn't feel like,
okay,
I got to make a big deal about eating.
It felt more like a survival technique,
like eating all day and then my mind,
I felt I did feel more energy.
I never felt like that after eating I
always felt like,
okay,
I can eat and then still go do
something.
I could go play cards or run around or
you know,
chase a friend or do anything,
hang out.
Yeah.
The um,
so who do you think you would have to?
You have to first of all,
talk to everybody about because you got,
like I said,
you got two weeks,
right?
You got two weeks for your body can just
go on fat.
So you're going to start using itself.
It,
that your body starts eating itself.
Okay.
You got to talk to people and say,
listen,
this person is dead,
okay,
this is just meat now that can keep us
alive and we can survive and we could
see our family and our friends or we
cannot eat this person and would take a
chance on going hungry and we might get
too weak to get outta here.
Like you have to think like,
what if,
what if you can get saved,
but you have to be able to hike out 30
miles in the mountains.
Okay,
so now you really planning ahead.
Then a lot of you have to.
You have to you you're,
you're either going to die or you're
going to live.
Okay.
These are the only two things that could
possibly happen.
The Internet even mattered at this
point,
so you've got to figure out,
is it even possible that you can live?
Is it possible you might be?
Might not be.
You might be in the mountains in the
winter with nothing around you to eat,
no way for you to get off the mountain
because it's too dangerous because you
get cliffed out every time he tried to
go down and then try to get back up and
you can't get back up and you're stuck.
You could fall and die.
It happens to people all the time,
so it might not be that you can make it,
but if you are going to make it out,
you're going to want to have some energy
and so different people have different
fitness levels obviously,
so some people like they're not even
going to be capable of hiking out.
Would it be take a lunch.
I mean,
you don't have to eat the whole person.
Right?
Then like you guys could.
You would eat them in parts for sure.
What would you have?
It's a psychologically devastating.
The thought of just eating human meat.
It's psychologically devastating.
You.
You're crossing a threshold that you
know you're in,
you're into.
It's a dark art.
To me,
it's everything.
It's everything.
It's sad.
It's crazy and it's also a rich part of,
you know,
human adventure history.
There was always like,
you run into cannibals,
you know,
it was like a pig part of those crazy
movies about it in the jungle.
They got eaten by cannibals.
Even Brady Bunch.
Remember they came across some people,
I think they were cannibals weren't
cannibal,
but like all,
even cartoons,
all of them did.
It was cannibals or like a joe versus
the volcano.
Remember that.
And I don't remember that.
I think he came across cannonballs well
there was saying Hannibal's in history.
A lot of cannibals.
I didn't know that there was so much
cannibalism amongst native Americans.
Native Americans would cannibalize
settlers.
They would.
Some of them like the Nez perce Indians.
Steve knows telling me about that.
They would cut dudes up and eat them.
Like,
Whoa,
that's,
that's crazy.
Imagine.
Yeah.
If somebody goes down and you're this
and there's a part you already know,
you like it.
Like,
I'm cutting this dude's sand.
I'm having a little bit of fucking
ligament right here on this hillside.
Rough man.
The guy got killed by a polar bear
yesterday in front of his kids in
Canada.
He was protecting his kids from the
polar bear
and uh,
he died 31 year old dude.
You know what,
that's a hero though.
I mean,
these kids will think of him as a hero.
A bet he lives in that same place where
those people live on that life below
zero.
I think it's called nunavet
people's lives.
He lives.
Uh,
I mean he lives in a really,
really remote area that has polar bears.
Polar bears are the most dangerous bear
you could ever run into because they are
the only animal that all,
all of them actively hunt people.
Really?
Nunavut.
That's the place where it was.
Yeah.
They,
they hunt everything.
Everything that moves.
They don't.
They don't have any vegetables up there.
So the,
they're the only 100 percent carnivorous
bear.
All they eat is meat.
All Day is meet.
Every other.
Bear is like eating berries and berries
or ignore you.
If they've got a whole field for a
barrier.
I not chase you asshole to your bones
and all that bullshit.
I'm just gonna eat beverage,
Lazy Vas.
I did some various laying on his back.
They love berries and you find like
giant fields of blueberries.
You'll find bears just snacking away,
having a great time eating blueberries.
They'll do it all day.
Not Polar bears.
Polar bears eat your asshole.
I'll kill you.
They kill everything,
man.
I would hate that.
I would.
If someone was trying to eat me,
man,
I would just be so upset.
I think.
Yeah.
Did you see that lady that got in
trouble because she shot a giraffe?
She shot him that she shot a rare
giraffe and so everybody's freaking out
on her.
It seemed sad,
man.
That giraffe seemed like it probably
wasn't going to do to her.
It's not going to do anything to her for
sure.
It's a.
It is rare for an animal to get that
old.
It's 18 years old.
It's real dark.
You haven't had dark skin or something.
A little bit of the old males.
They get dark.
That's super cool.
One thing though that people need to
know.
See,
all these things are complicated.
They're not as simple as everybody wants
to think they are,
and this is one of the things that's
complicated about this store is that
that draft was killing little giraffes.
It's a normal thing.
The old bowls like that one,
which is a big,
massive 18 year old animal,
a huge,
huge animal.
Uh,
he just was not having it with these
young ones coming up,
not having it.
What do you think it is?
Jealousy or anger?
It's just nature.
You know,
they,
they kill off the younger males,
like pissed at the neighbor kids kind of
thing.
Don't.
They just don't want anybody taking
their spot.
They don't know that they're riding off
into the sunset.
Like he's not a viable breeding male
anymore,
but still huge.
So at 18 years of age,
he had killed off three young bowls.
So they were going to have to kill him.
Right.
Because it's not good.
You need the bulls to keep the thing
alive.
What was,
well,
not just that he.
This is a species of giraffe that
already has a population problem.
There's not a lot of them.
And if he's killing off these young
bowls,
each one of those young bulls could have
fathered countless children.
So they're missing all these future
children for one bull who can't even
breed anymore.
And he's going to continue to do it.
He was seeking out the young bulls.
Yeah.
Already killed three.
Like this is not a cut and dry thing.
I don't think it looks cool to pose with
a rifle and a giraffe.
And
I mean there's something about giraffes
that are so gentle that they let kids
feed them when you go to the fucking
zoo.
Right?
I don't.
So I get why people would be upset.
But when you find out what it actually
is,
you go,
oh,
this is not as,
this is more complicated than I'm.
Than I'm seeing on the surface.
It's not simply a cruel person shot a
giraffe and we should be angry at her.
It's like,
no,
they had to shoot that giraffe because
it was killing other giraffes.
So is it appropriate the way she
celebrated it?
That's when you have to wonder,
you know,
but they were eating it.
I mean,
that's the other thing.
It's like they got fucking 800 pounds of
meat or something like that out of that.
Wow.
That's a huge animal.
I think it was more than that.
Then they say 2000 pounds of meat.
I think it's a 4,000 pound animal and
they got 2000 pounds of meat,
which they give to all the villages.
All the people there and I know people
like,
wait,
I don't give a fuck.
You shouldn't shoot a draft.
I feel the same way because when I see a
giraffe I don't think of it as something
I want to shoot and eat.
I think of it as something a little kid
can feed at the fucking zoo because
they're so gentle.
They're so gentle that they like people
feed them.
Oh yeah.
They had a thing by our home when I was
growing up,
they had a thing dude at a couple of
giraffes out there,
a couple of lambs and shit.
You can get out there and buy a little
cup of corn and go out there and you
don't even have to know.
Like you don't have to sign away.
You don't have to do anything,
you don't even have to fucking be able
to read very well and you could fucking
feed a Giraffe,
you know,
point blank is the only animal that is a
wild African animal that we let kids
feed at the fucking zoo.
Little kids can feed them.
Yeah.
I can't believe that there's that much.
I mean,
when I hear that for one,
the lady,
what did she,
why did she have to put that picture
out?
What was in it for her to do that?
If she even knew like she's a hunter and
she was excited that you got to kill a
big giraffe,
you know,
and the,
it gets.
It's,
it gets strange when you just kill a
bunch of things and make stuff.
Trophies and you put them in your trophy
room and you go,
well I want to get it now.
I want to get a Ram.
Okay,
I got a ramp.
Now I want to get a mountain goat.
I'll get it.
And you got like this menagerie inside
of your house.
That's it gets dark man.
Now I want to get a mouse.
Now.
I want to get a stepdad now.
I want to get a fucking.
But then is like,
okay,
but if you're eating all of those things
and this is how you get your meat.
Yeah.
Is that okay?
Well,
yeah,
that's okay,
but there's something.
There's something.
We all have a strange feeling about
this.
The idea is that people are killing
these things and they're getting some
kind of pleasure out of it and then not
doing it just to eat it.
Right.
It's not like even if you you are going
to eat it,
we don't want you to be really happy
when you kill something.
That's too.
That's some of it.
I think the villagers should it be able
to.
Ones that should vote on if it was okay
or not.
It's in their village.
They would vote okay every time because
they get money from it.
Then to me then that seems okay because
a lot of times it's like we're judging
things from so far away.
We don't even know.
We didn't even know what it's like.
We're talking about completely different
dynamics in terms of like the way their
culture works.
First of all,
the money for these big hunt so that
these
people pay to shoot all these different
things down there.
That's a shitload of money and that shit
load of money for that area,
for that part of the world is gigantic
fuels conservation efforts.
It pays for these people that are
essentially their version of game
wardens,
you know,
um,
and then they have these different
people that are employed by these
hunting companies and then there's
resources to stop poaching and then
resources to actively participate in
controlling habitat and making sure
these animals are in healthy populations
and bringing their numbers up.
This is all done through the money that
comes from hunting them.
So it's super,
it's super fucked up.
Right.
It's,
it's weird because it doesn't make
sense.
It's like the people that are paying to
keep these animal alive are also the
ones that want to shoot up.
So people are like,
what the F we would like it to be.
All the conservation money comes from
people who just love animals and want to
keep them alive.
But that's not the case.
That's not the case.
No.
The money comes almost exclusively
because there are a lot of conservation
groups that do donate for wildlife
protection and for preserving of animal
habitats.
There are,
there's,
there's definitely some people that
donate,
right.
But there's no,
it's not even close to the amount of
money that's raised from hunting to and
especially hunting you on that local
level.
Like you're a,
you know,
like some of these,
like these programs,
I'm sure there are a little bit more
bigger,
more blanket,
you know,
but you get into that local level.
$50,000 can keep,
you know,
a small town or small habitat around for
the year,
that money who was getting all that
money.
But you're right,
it's.
But it's,
it makes us uncomfortable.
But rightly so.
I mean,
you look at a Giraffe,
you want giraffes to stay alive.
You say like,
that's amazing,
but we have to know the facts behind it.
In this particular case where they,
that giraffe had to go,
that draft was killing giraffes.
You ever seen him fight?
It's the most familiar thing.
They just had buddy each other.
They swing their head like,
oh,
like a mace smash into each other.
It's what a terrible way to fight.
It's fucking crazy.
Suck at fighting Esophagus fucking.
It's like Krista.
It's almost like Chris delea.
Maybe if you were in height
and I'm just saying that a love.
Absolutely love you.
Love as a Sophos,
a very prominent target.
If you wanted to hit something,
have you seen this funny thing,
this Jaguar Challenge?
Instagram.
He's silly.
He's so surprised.
Very silly.
Sometimes you don't really like,
dude,
he is.
He's so funny and he's an a.
he's so fucking funny.
Very good dude.
And very funny.
Very silly.
He's just sick.
He's got his own kind of con.
His own kind of funny.
Yeah.
And he lives.
And he's so confident and living in that
space,
man.
It's kind of um,
uh,
yeah.
It's,
it's interesting.
It kind of gets to really get to know
that guy.
Well that's what you know,
it is with you too.
It's like your kind of,
you,
you do your kind of funny.
And that's a,
that's an interesting thing.
Like when someone finds their,
like we're talking about Mitch Hedberg
the other day,
like he had his kind of funny like you
could see you'd hear Mitch Hedberg joke
and you go,
oh,
that's a,
that's a Hedburg joke.
That's how he does his kind of funny.
Yeah.
It's so funny,
man.
Well thanks for saying that man.
Appreciate that.
Yeah,
I think it's like,
as I've gotten a little bit older,
it's made me feel more comfortable to
just be myself,
you know,
for so long out here.
I'll just felt if I was just afraid to
be myself self esteem,
you know,
who I was,
it's all those things,
man,
you know,
it's hard trying to be trying to be
confident in what you're doing is a
confidence destroying a way to make a
living,
you know?
And I get intimidated.
I would get intimidated easy.
Like this is the first time I've
actually even felt kind of a little bit
more comfortable being in here.
Really?
Yeah.
In here?
Like I don't know if it's not you,
it's just something with me,
you know?
It's just something I don't know.
I don't know if it's like,
if I feel like if there's like men that
are more like kind of physically,
you know,
in shape or just sitting things maybe
inside of me somewhere that make me feel
I'm just on,
you know,
uh,
I don't know what it is.
It's what people worry about being
bullied.
For sure.
People develop like A.
I feel it sometimes I'm around people
really.
Oh No,
I was thinking about that.
You like hanging out around like real
rare hang out around some real rare
animal humans.
You know,
superhuman.
That Daniel Cormier.
Dude,
that's super human.
That big coffee.
Jon Jones who human.
Yeah.
Mighty mouse.
Amy's a small superhuman.
George St Pierre Superhuman.
Have you ever been in an elevator with
them or something and be like,
we're a bunch of those dudes.
Just fucking kill me.
Kill you.
Anytime they want.
You have to deal with that feeling.
It's not the best fit as crazy.
Well,
you're talking to Francis in Ghana.
That's always in your mind.
No matter what you guys are talking
about is a part of you that says if you
want to do,
he could just kill me like that.
Do you get scared with?
Sometimes.
Honestly,
like I get scared for you whenever you
have to go in the ring after the fights.
Do you ever get scared?
A little bit,
dude.
The first time I ever interviewed
anybody ever after a fight,
I had an interview Mark Coleman after he
choked out Dan several.
And this was in like UFC fucking 12.
So that was 1997.
And uh,
Mark Coleman was so fired up man because
he had just won the heavyweight title
fucking jacked.
He was so jacked and uh,
he was fucking pumped up and he had no
idea Bayer for that movie doesn't even,
he was the king of the world back then.
Mark the hammer,
coleman changed the fucking game.
Look at the.
Because she was like a real world class
wrestler,
taken dudes down and just smashing them
any was fucking huge,
huge,
you know.
And so I had to interview first
interview anybody and had no idea who I
was.
And it was like,
Oh fuck is this guy interviewing?
But I ask respectful questions and then
gave him an opportunity to express
himself and it
worked out.
But I prepared for that man.
I was nervous.
Wow.
Whew.
I was nervous.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Because it's,
to me,
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this guy,
you know,
this man is going into the cage after
lunch.
Yup.
That's what he does.
How you.
That's it.
I felt like me.
But like when you go like,
you know,
I'm not,
uh,
you know,
these,
these guys are very,
some of these admin are very physically
imposing to me.
Like.
And so when you,
sometimes I'm like,
man,
I can't believe that you go in there.
It's just brave as well.
No one thing that I think they all know.
And if they don't know,
I want them to know that I don't want
anything other than them to shine.
That's all I'm trying to do.
Like when I interview people,
but I'm trying to do is give them an
opportunity to talk about moments.
I just want to give them a chance to
shine,
show who they are.
I want them to feel comfortable.
I look out for their best interests a
really do I try to do that with
commentary.
Even if it sounds critical,
my critical commentary is just expose.
Like I look at it in terms of I'm
looking at it like it's a math problem
or a system and if I see things I'm
like,
this is.
This is an issue.
Even if the person can win with this
issue,
this is a real issue.
Like a a high level person is gonna
exploit that issue.
Maybe this guy can't do it,
but this.
Sometimes people get upset at that.
That does happen,
but I say,
listen,
I have to bose.
It made me think I exaggerate,
but believe me,
those fucking high class killers that
see the same shit that I see,
they're going to try to exaggerate that
shit too,
that you're going to try to jump on that
little hole.
There's a little hole somewhere and that
happens all the time with people that
get mad.
If you point out their holes,
it doesn't mean they can't win.
There's guys who've gotten their entire
career,
they rarely throw a kick.
They never submit anybody and there some
of the best of all time that you don't
have to have a fully complete game.
Sometimes it's better to just be ultra
good at one or two things and those
other things just don't fuck with
submissions,
you know,
just don't fuck with me of uh,
there's,
there's people that are like that.
They take someone's back,
they never choke them.
They just keep punching them.
They never took anybody.
There's a lot of people like that.
And then there's right
coons on with raccoons.
Do that.
Will get read a raccoon on.
You never had a raccoon on me.
Have you?
Oh yeah,
they bite you dude.
If you ever have one bite you a have.
I have one.
I've had maybe buy it.
I mean I got scratched or bitten.
I mean I had to get all the rabies
shots.
I mean,
I grew up in like the rabies bill,
you know,
so you'd,
you'd,
uh,
and they group up raccoons.
Do the raccoons are.
They are.
I can't believe we can't shut all that
shit down.
How many of them are roaming the streets
at night?
A lot.
Pro.
How crazy stare you down,
bro.
You ever seen Madagascar and they're
fucking.
They're everywhere.
Did I lived in.
I lived in new Rochelle,
New York and uh,
they used to have these urban raccoon.
Oh yeah.
Different kinds of raccoon.
Raccoons that live in high density areas
are bolder species and they have access
to massive amounts of food.
They just would lift off the lid from
the garbage.
Can they lift off lid to get
inside the garbage?
Can they tear the garbage bags?
All but.
And they'd just be sitting there staring
at you to look.
And Jack looked at Gold's gym tank top
on like they were big.
I was like,
how is that a Raghu that's a big animal.
Yeah.
So I bought a blow gun.
Shoot Darts.
You did.
I did.
These motherfuckers were wreck my
garbage and you're like,
shit overnight be sleeping.
And I hear the Dang look at him climbing
up.
Do we have one?
And what is he doing?
He's going to get that bird feeder and
unscrew the bird.
He's doing my God.
Look how smart is.
Dude.
This is insane.
Oh,
smart.
This thing is.
But also look how confident it is and
its strength.
And look at him looking over the camera.
He knows he's being filmed.
And look how he's,
you know,
I don't think he knows that,
but look,
look how,
how good he is at climbing up.
I mean,
this is crazy.
The amount of physical strength is,
fucker has.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Just let all that seed go and now was
hand partying like crazy and they fuck
today.
You can hear them at night.
We used to live,
uh,
we used to hear a bunch of them having
sex at night and you could hear 'em.
You can go outside and even in a
residential neighborhood,
dude,
there's 70 of them on your blog.
Like there's so many raccoons living
amongst us that it's,
it blows my mind that it's not a bigger
issue.
Pull that up again.
Look with the video dude.
How many people,
even if they could do that,
if they had the kind of strength to do
that,
how many people would even figure out
how to navigate that so easily to Matt
iseman would host this.
This is like American Ninja Warrior.
Do you telling me that they don't steal
some of these games from this fucker?
Look at him.
He stopped going full screen because
when it goes full screen starts,
I don't know what the hell is happening.
Look at this.
And he said,
okay,
China person or something.
Look at his fucking ability to just hang
on there with one arm and then grabbed
with his feet.
That is bananas.
What is that called?
An in UFC.
Is that a move?
Uh,
no.
It doesn't exist.
I guess.
Maybe jumped to guard.
Yeah,
we kind of jumped into garden.
It's amazing
what he can do.
His little bodies.
Just crazy.
Yeah.
How much core strength is a raccoon?
Have to have to do that.
Oh Dude,
so much.
And they garbage.
It's just freezing.
I hit pause on perfect.
They can eat newspaper.
How crazy is that?
Can they can play that,
but keep going this,
look at this,
but look how comfortable he is hanging
from his fingers with all four limbs.
Like he's just chilling.
He's not worried that something's going
to happen.
He's like,
hmm,
let me just scoot my ass up here.
Climb,
climb,
climb.
I'm just going to twist this fucker off
here.
Look at him.
He's hanging on with his legs and he
could just cracked it open and now look
at this reverse.
Look at this
at the end,
but the crazy thing is he could hold
onto that plastic tube with his hands
and feet to of each two of his hands or
to have his feet or their hands.
Look at the size of their body,
their hands.
This big tiny.
Could you imagine having a little bitty
baby hand and having to do something.
I know,
right?
Look how much smarter hand is in their
face.
You'd have hands like a four year old
girl.
Imagine opening a door,
but you can't even open a door.
You just have to stare at a door knob
with little bro.
I'm talking the littlest hands.
Tiny.
They'll fuck you up to those things.
Yeah.
Raccoons eat a lot of chickens too.
They like to get into chicken coops.
Fuck up chickens.
They would jump on your back.
It was almost the.
Here's the crazy thing I remember about
being around raccoons.
It felt like they were playing with you,
but had an immediate propensity for
violence like gay could go like very
quick from fun and comfortable to
extremely violent.
It makes sense.
I mean,
what a rough and tumble world.
The world of the raccoons mother fucker.
They live at night.
Look at your swing the door.
Look at this now.
I think this is a close the door here
and it opens it again.
My grandmother had a friend that had a
couple
so he just knows how to open doors.
Creepy.
Fuck.
There's something weird about them.
Just a strange animal that like almost
seems like it shouldn't be real.
You know,
like a smart,
weird animal that lives in the forest.
Like you expected to start talking to a
little kid that's on a walk.
Like who?
Who are you?
Where are you from?
And it's.
Yeah,
it's got dice and it's little hand one
dice.
This turnover.
Your grandmother won't mind if you hang
out with me.
Show you a house.
It's made of candy.
Yeah.
You want some lipstick?
Putting lipstick on her creepy animals,
but that's weird to me.
The weirder animals,
the animals that have adapted to living
right next to people that them.
Coyotes.
That's them.
Are you telling me about a coyote you
had at your house?
I've got a bunch of them at my house.
They're just in the,
you know in the hills.
If you live anywhere around la in
particular,
anywhere that there's some trees and
shit in between the houses,
guess what?
You got?
Coyotes.
They just fucking live everywhere,
man.
I saw him on all of in Burbank the other
day,
driving up all of our soft fucking
coyotes.
I was like,
whoa.
Somebody who reported a cody fight in my
neighborhood when I was growing up and
it was somebody made that up,
but the cops still showed up and I
remember they interviewed everybody
like,
we fucking do anything about it.
Do you think kind of what he's fight
wonder if they do fight with each other?
I don't think I've ever heard of him
fighting at this.
It must make sense.
Someone has to be the boss and the
coyote world.
Wolves.
Do Wolves.
Fuck each other up.
Do they really?
Yeah.
So awful to kill each other.
So He's a coyote.
Fights here.
Most intense coyote.
Oh,
look at this.
They're going to war right here it is on
Worldstar.
That's where you draw back right there.
Look at that.
And other one jumped in.
Three coyotes strategically held by
Bush.
Do you fuck they're fucking each other
up.
Dude.
Do you think we could ever get to the
point where you know that humans fight
animals like they did back in the old
days?
You know,
like gladiator style?
Yeah.
Seriously though.
You could do that in another country for
sure.
Yeah.
If somebody from some crazy country
where they had some maniacal dicker
dictator who's on crystal meth and he
decided to have humans versus lions
given to a sword and the shield and
armor and him.
Fuck up a 100 percent.
Do you think that goes on?
Um,
I wouldn't say no.
Yeah,
because I think there's people with
enough money,
like fucking crazy,
crazy prints money.
Oh yeah.
If there are prints of some crazy
country,
there's people just probably can't get
satisfied.
It's not.
They can't get any.
Hillary's.
Yeah.
Cocaine,
pussy,
jets.
Oh,
islands in France.
Like what else do I want?
What else I want?
I want to watch a dude fight a lion with
a sword.
Yeah.
This is probably like some place that
you can go.
Right.
And it's got like a drains in the floor
where they hose it down from all the
blood and it's built like a hockey rink.
Yeah.
But uh,
the floor underneath the floor,
this is zoo just like that.
They used to do it in the Roman days and
uh,
it rises up,
they let the animal out,
close it down and then they opened the
cage and the fucking dude stands there
with the sword and the crowd goes and
they're all listening to techno music
and speak in Dutch.
And then
suddenly we know where they are at.
Dude,
in that fucking lie.
And Go to war.
They go at it,
man.
Yeah.
He think he has like face paint on or
anything or he's just [inaudible].
It was probably a good move.
Pull a face.
Paint on.
You need every edge.
Yeah.
You know you got to fight a line with a
sword.
You probably gonna get killed.
You're going to cut the line and then
get killed.
That's what you're going to do.
Then you get one good hit at it.
If you're lucky.
Probably won't even really it.
Yeah.
You swordman yeah.
You.
You don't have any idea how slow you are
until you're around a cat that kills
antelopes and shit.
Chases after willdabeast takes him out
with his face.
You're just that you.
You have no idea.
I think everybody.
No,
I don't think you get a shot off.
I think with the cat wants to the cats
on you so fast.
You barely have time to move your arm.
That's what I think.
I don't think.
Yeah.
I don't think you have any idea how fast
a.
like a real Predator moves and how
ridiculously soft human beings are.
Right.
Especially if you're not.
Some.
I don't fucking Conan the barbarian due
to can actually swing a sword,
a heavy sword with some fucking oomph
behind it.
Yeah.
You ever pick up a real sword?
It's heavy as shit,
man.
It's fucking heavy and it's sharp.
It's almost scary to have one sometimes.
Yeah.
Like fuck.
I would hurt myself or I'd cut my cousin
up or something on accident or had hurt
somebody at the house.
Yeah.
The odds of you killing that lion with
one swipe or almost zero,
you're going to get fucked up.
Okay.
How would you attack it then?
Say you're in a place.
You've got this sword.
Maybe got one other weapon,
a small weapon you keep on your leg or
something.
The only way
that I think you have a chance is if you
can keep your shit together and plugins
that blade and it's chest as it leaps on
you
as the only way you would have to be
ready to as it comes at you to push
forward and hold onto that sword with
everything you have as it's coming at
you and the blade goes into its body.
That might be the only way,
and even then it's going to walk you and
rip you apart.
You want.
You're not going to be able to.
It's not possible.
I think he could do it to.
Nope.
You don't think you could.
No.
And you would keep both hands on.
Now.
That's how you acted it out.
You keep both hands on it.
You are not going to be able to hang on.
You're just not.
It's a different kind of power.
It's the power of many,
many men.
It's like the idea of a who borrowed.
You think you could win a tug of war
with 10 dudes?
Yeah.
Fuck Yeah Bro.
Most guys are bitches.
Do you have a chance?
There's a strength level.
You'd have to be like some Herculean,
Marriott's,
Pooja,
Nowatzski type dudes.
Some enormous fucking world's strongest
man guy with chalk all over your hands
and a good grip on the blade and maybe
tie it down like a Rodeo rider plunging
into the heart of a lion.
And even then,
I don't think you're hanging onto it.
I think that things gonna Book and kick
and and you're going to be so terrified
if it's a male lion,
you get to see that main in that face
and your body scare you.
You're going to get diminished.
Yeah.
You're going to be so overwhelmed with
adrenaline.
Your instinct is going to be to just run
away from that thing as far as you can.
Do you feel like some truths as like any
truths,
like any innate truth would be revealed
as you're,
as you're sitting here looking at each
other's eyes and you know that it's
going to kill you.
I don't think you're even there at that
point.
I think if you're.
I think you're such a primal experience
that I think at that point you are
probably.
You're barely a human.
You're just a series of synapses firing
that are designed to protect you from
predators.
I think you just in full panic,
full adrenaline rush,
full survival mode where you don't.
You don't know what the fuck is going
on.
I have some friends.
Fuck man.
I've got some friends that got a
taxpayer there.
They got attacked by a giant grizzly
bear and they.
No,
everybody got away survived luckily,
but they were in.
They were in an island off of Alaska,
of fog neck island,
and it's a huge population of brown
bears and elk and they all lived
together.
These,
these fucking parents are huge and this
bear,
which was like an 11 foot bear,
charged into their camp and knocked
everyone over like guys were flying left
and right.
One of the dudes is a nicknames.
Dartmouth,
Dartmouth was riding on the back.
If you want to hear the whole story and
it's a great story,
go to the mediator and I think the
episodes just say a fog.
Neck island.
I don't know if it says bear attack on a
fog neck island,
but if you're a.
If you're a clever googler,
you'll find it's a great podcast.
Anyway,
Steve Rainelle is a genius.
He's a really interesting guy and a
hunter,
like we just totally,
totally
defies the stereotype that people have
of like doofy hunters like super well
read.
Really interesting guy,
but his depiction of this event,
the most striking thing about it was
that it defied everything that he
thought it would be like if there was an
actual bear attack.
Sounds like hemingway esque almost in a
weird way.
Well know in a weird way.
Yeah.
Because when look,
if something really fucking crazy
happens,
the best case scenario is there someone
who actually knows how to write.
That's right there.
When this something crazy happened and
this is the case,
but instead of writing it,
he just does a very eloquent job of
describing it as does everybody else
there.
I mean,
there was quite a few guys there.
My friend Rammi Warren was there and
Yonis will tell us this is one where
they got um,
false attacked.
This was in British Columbia.
They got false charged of false charge
is a bear this,
in this case,
it was a bear with cubs and she just
want to scare them off.
So she came running at them full clip.
It's crazy to see because they fired
near her,
but they had the discipline to not fire
her.
I'm like,
that is really impressive because this
thing just came fucking running at them
and it's huge.
Like here it is.
Like give me some volume here.
Oh my God,
I will shoot to kill this
peels off man's away and Callahan says
I'll never forget.
I want to give them a tee shirt with him
and his mustache and this smell us now
it smells now lady.
That's a sentence that comes to mind,
so that is what he had experienced
before and so he,
he kind of kept his composure in that
situation and he was like this other one
where the grizzly bear literally knocked
them over to the teeth were gnashing 10
inches from his face.
It was just so many people.
The grizzly probably didn't expect there
to be that many people there.
There was like seven people there is
that my views.
Let me think of how many people.
One,
two,
three.
At least five people there and I think
that's what saved him,
but the camera people to is.
It probably was about seven people and I
think that's what saved them.
The fact that this was a giant mass of
people and the bear didn't know which
way to go,
and one of the dudes Yanas hit it in the
face with trekking poles.
You know,
there's trekking poles.
He said it was right there,
smacked in the face and thing.
Veered off.
One of the guys,
remy,
he juked it.
He faked right.
And then went laugh on the bear.
There was just so much going on.
The bear just ran through it.
One of the guys wound
up on the bears back now for like 10
yards there was running and he was
somehow into the stuck on the bears back
and then fell off.
This is how big the bear was in.
I think we need to see a bear,
man.
You don't think it's going to be like
that,
that intense,
you know,
you don't think it because the first
picture they showed that bear,
he seemed like a calm Bayer,
you know,
look at that bear.
I've seen him in.
The worst thing about bears is they
advertise them mostly Disney movies.
How do you see a bear teddy bear?
You know what I'm saying?
Uh,
you know,
they have fucking bearish fucking to on
the Internet,
you have all that kind of shit,
but it's like sweeties.
Yes,
they're your buddy.
They're your buddy.
Meanwhile,
how about those little kids that their
dad got eaten in front of them?
I mean,
what do those little kids,
what if they had a little pet polar bear
that's not outside the realm of
possibility with little kids and you get
convinced that that's what those animals
are.
Look,
I'm not saying you shouldn't have a pet
stuffed polar bear.
They're cute.
It's not a path.
But you know what I'm saying?
A toy.
Would you have a little barrier thing as
a pet?
No fucking way.
Man released.
Ridiculous.
He seemed like a guy that might have a
little vague to that dude.
Fuck that.
First of all,
they're not listening to you.
Get Away with all that.
They might be your friend,
it might be your friend as they grow
older,
but you better keep that food around
bitch.
And even if you have that food around,
you can't keep them from killing other
people.
Like there was a guy who has his bear
trained look at the size of that fucker.
Oh my God,
this guy's definitely probably.
this was like a gay.
If you keep this animal fed,
there are people that have bears.
Does this in Russia is Russia.
Yeah.
So if there's people that keep bears fed
and take care of them and treat them
well,
you know,
and this is the thing about bears too,
is at burt bears are omnivores.
They eat everything.
Oh really?
Hate animals.
They vegetables,
they eat everything.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
They're like people in a lot of way in
that they are,
you know,
their diet very so they don't have to
eat,
they don't have to kill things.
Didn't necessarily have the desire to
chase things down and killed things like
a cat does.
Like cats have a deep desire to kill
things.
Like cats can't shake that shit.
Yeah,
I think you could,
you could feed a bear well and take care
of it and you could probably avoid most
of that.
But if it ever feels threatened in any
way,
you're so fucked.
And do you think you have any like
there,
you might not even notice when that bear
feels that way,
but I wouldn't.
I'm not a beer expert.
I think a real bear expert would see
that something's weird.
The Bears Act and sketchy
or bears like.
Yeah,
they just.
They start acting irritated.
Look at the size of these things,
man.
This guy is definitely a pervert.
You think so?
Yeah.
This because I think there's got to be
something inside of you that gets off in
a weird way to do this.
I don't think this feels natural.
I think they're intoxicated by powerful
animals and having these powerful
animals around gives them a thrill.
Okay.
The thrill has to be.
Do you think that that,
that they could kill him.
That's it.
One hundred percent.
And also did like
the thrill is they are beautiful
creatures,
so you do want to be around them.
They're cool to just be around and if
you,
you can make friends with this beautiful
creature that could just kill a mass of
people.
It's kind of feels fun.
Dangerous.
Yeah.
That's cool.
It feels dangerous.
It's like a celebrity.
It's like no one else,
John or are way better.
You got a pet grizzly come over my
house,
motherfucker.
I got a 12 foot dog that lives in my
house,
you know,
like,
but cats seed.
That's it.
No more.
These are different animals.
This is a different thing,
but I think if people have an animal
like that,
they're fucking next to it at night and
they're doing.
I think some of them shouldn't be.
Yeah,
probably near it.
I don't think they're getting involved
with them,
but I think they're doing near it.
But just fuck right next to the tiger
and get them horny.
What do beastiality needs?
Because I've thought this about
beastiality and I don't know if we've
even talked about this,
but if you have sex with a local animal,
something that lives here,
how livestock,
chickens,
something like that.
It's fucked up.
It's fucked up and it's not,
you know,
travel overseas with the specific
intention of having sex with an animal.
Okay.
That's,
to me,
that's so fucked up.
You know,
the rules are different depending on who
you ask.
Probably locally,
but I'm sure in some places they're like
me some money and you can do whatever
you want it.
I go,
no,
but if you.
If you fuck a mountain lion,
that's a strong man.
That's how I.
that's it,
Dude.
You never buy a beer again.
You fuck a mountain?
You fuck a links that to me,
that's not beastiality.
To me,
that's like some Ragnar Loft Brooke type
Shit.
Yeah.
That's the bravest thing you can do.
That's a viking shit.
Imagine a trying to keep an erection and
then sneak up on a bucket animals,
but you'd have to.
You have to figure out a way to hold him
down and you think there's ever a guy
the best of the mountain line then
fucked it.
See,
I
don't think.
I believe there might be another Theo
Vaughn or an infinite number of them out
in the universe talking to another me
and that were sitting in the exact same.
The exact same notes.
I believe that.
I'm not sure I believe any of those
people on any of those plants that have
planets ever fucked a mountain lion.
I don't know.
A long time ago.
You don't think that when?
No,
but there's no youtube.
There was nobody to tell.
The only person who knows is the other
two people.
People are gonna think they're lying
because they're alcoholics.
You could eat.
I don't think so,
dude.
I don't think there's any squirrels that
rape people either.
You know what I'm saying?
I think that that's more likely.
It's more likely that a squirrel would
rape a person.
Oh,
I could see a school kind of funk.
Someone's drunk who passed out in their
yard.
That's more likely.
Like a crazy super horny squirrel.
Just can't keep it together.
He keeps [inaudible] up.
Yeah.
Some Kappa Delta just passed out on her
fucking yard.
You know,
had many peanut butter.
Crazy.
I do not think that a guy could fuck
them out in line.
I just don't think that's ever happened.
Especially not gay sex.
Right.
Maybe a female mountain lion might let
you.
She's all wild up and heat and why
eat my friend,
wasn't it Chris Ryan talked about
fucking his cat with a pencil.
Did he gave me a shirt?
Salt.
That's right.
He did.
That's his shirt.
He tells a great story about his cat was
in heat and she backed up to him.
She was like trying to get some Dick and
he put a pencil in their giddy,
like a little kid.
He was like a little kid.
Yes.
Sherry was an adult sexual experience.
Was this cat backing up on this pencil?
Yeah,
I could imagine.
I did.
I remember getting like an erection and
just,
I remember just hold it against fucking
did.
I remember being at the library when I
was young and this is back when they
had,
um,
books,
you know,
what do they have now?
I mean,
you don't fucking know her library still
open.
Who's hitting their.
Just people trying to finger each other.
Who was in a fucking liar.
You even imagined,
I guess books about homeless people
allow homeless people in libraries.
Yeah.
Can we just start calling them shelters?
You know what I'm saying?
And serve lunch.
But I remember going in there and the
only sex you could see at the time,
it was like Rodin or something like
that.
Or these old artists remember they would
paint like a reuben ask one by shooting
him and shoot.
But like this,
you see breasts instead of one of her
hands.
Like this weird thing with the hands.
Right?
Everything was always this way.
Why is that?
But I remember like opposed indicative
of a certain time and history I guess
because it's really hard to draw a hand.
Oh,
that could be it.
Maybe somebody drew it.
But if you think that like emperors
would stand there and do this to their,
to their people like you now look,
there's two things to trump could do
that.
People would freak the fuck out.
One of them obviously he's like a sieg
Heil.
Yeah,
that's bad.
The other one that might be just as bad
as the emperor.
He comes out with one hand almost like
he's holding an invisible football.
On the other hand,
do this and just addressed to people.
People will blow a gasket.
He wants to be.
The emperor wants me to Buckingham for.
Oh my God,
dude,
he should start wearing a crown.
How great would it be if he started
wearing a crown?
Dude?
It would be hilarious if you started
wearing like a cheap burger.
King one just didn't say nothing about
it.
I bet he will.
Do you think he.
I think he has a sense of humor.
He definitely does.
Yeah.
He definitely.
He's the first president that has ever
been roasted on comedy central.
Oh,
that's a great point,
dude.
He got roasted on comedy central and
Jeff Ross even said to him like,
like ya'll laughing at the jokes,
I could.
She'd probably laugh at them like,
don't,
don't.
It's probably people like it better if
you're going along with it.
He's like,
yeah,
you're right.
And then he loosened up and started
laughing.
So he takes advice from people that are
in the business.
They told some ruthless jokes about him.
Man.
He hung up.
Mary handled it.
I liked in keys,
resilient.
Whether or not he can feel any of that
because of his like,
uh,
whatever.
Ego spaces.
And I wonder how much of that even
feels,
but only he,
he might be the only human in America
could take this much hatred from people
at such a level that.
Yeah.
And it doesn't even care.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
it's fucking,
it's kind of awesome.
It's Kinda.
Oh,
I remember after he got elected driving
down the street and being like,
Holy Shit,
dude,
I could be president puking anybody.
That was what we thought when we were
kids,
to what's awesome about his.
And when I say awesome,
I don't mean good.
I mean amazing about his abilities.
Like all throughout all this crazy shit.
He doesn't show any signs of being like,
it doesn't seem to be like freaked out
right over the stormy Daniels Shit or
over the rush sugar,
all the investigations.
Occasionally he goes mad tweetstorm.
Yeah.
He seems to be the same guy he was
before.
He doesn't seem to be.
There's certain dudes when you see
something like,
um,
it was a good example.
Something fucked up happens to them and
you see it in their face.
They're like,
whoa.
Like George Bush,
whenever maybe on that video in the nine
slash one or whenever they see the
pictures and they told him about nine.
Well,
nine slash 11 was huge thing.
That's.
I don't think he knew how huge it was at
the time.
It was all breaking out.
You know,
the bad example.
Yeah.
But yeah,
trump just seems totally unaffected.
Just same.
No more senior citizens on twitter that,
that's a thing senior citizens on
twitter is kind of bizarre.
Oh,
there's a lot of them now.
They love it.
Will they take a break every couple of
minutes of doing facebook all day,
yelling at people on facebook.
Great.
Everybody hates.
The guy says,
I don't think everybody's.
I think a lot of people like the time
we're in right now because it's so.
It just,
I feel like you know what you're going
to get,
you know.
No,
it's,
it's a strange time for communication,
man.
It really is a strange time for
everything.
Yeah,
man.
It's uh,
it's different.
It's so different that it's fucking,
it's kind of fascinating.
I had,
um,
that got Jordan Peterson came on
podcast.
He hasn't met him on your podcast,
which was wild because I know his
publicist,
um,
and I reached out and the publicist,
and then it was wild and so then he came
through because I mean,
a lot of the people listen to my
podcast,
her,
you know,
we talk a lot about like being sober and
like people that masturbate too much,
kind of weird stuff,
you know,
troubled youths.
Kind of I'll say it,
right.
Um,
but anyway,
it was cool because he like,
I don't know,
you know,
better than I do.
Um,
he loves you.
He said a lot of Nice things about,
oh,
that's nice.
He's a great guy.
He's really misunderstood,
man.
Misrepresented people think he's some
fascist and some Nazi.
I didn't think that at all.
He's not by any stretch of the
imagination.
He just says certain things that people
are uncomfortable hearing and whether
you agree with them or disagree with
them,
that's one thing.
But that's what the demonization is
where it gets weird.
Even if you would think he's what his
idea is foolish.
Don't misrepresent who he is as a person
because they try to pretend that he's
this racist,
homophobic,
fucking character.
He's
not by any stretch of the imagination.
He's just a guy that especially when his
principles are being debated or when his
ideas are being tested like he,
he'll stand his ground and he's very
firm about what he thinks is wrong about
things like equality of outcome,
like making sure that everybody makes
the same amount of money,
make sure that everybody achieves the
same amount of success like that is a
ridiculous idea that leads to communism
and Marxism and he gets into it and it
made me rethink how I thought about it
before.
Then I thought about it before then,
like an unattainable goal that socialist
lean towards because it's like the
ideal.
The ideal is that money's not a concern
for anybody and everybody just sort of
does whatever they want to do because
they enjoy doing it,
not because they're doing it for money
and then all the money kind of piled in
together and we take care of everybody.
It sounds great on paper,
right?
But then he starts talking about,
no,
you have to enforce an equality of
outcome,
right?
He goes,
when you're talking about a quick,
there's going to be people that work
harder,
there's going to be able to try harder.
There's going to be different varying
levels of effort because we're human
beings.
You have to take that into consideration
and as soon as these people don't take
that into consideration,
it's then you're,
you're,
you're either trying to stop the people
that are doing too well or you're trying
to take from them to give to yourself
and how you enforcing this.
And he's,
he just takes you down this rabbit hole
of thought and really kind of explains
the problems with Marxism and socialism.
And I'm sure there's really intelligent
people that dispute his ideas.
I'm not saying that his ideas are
infallible or that he's the only voice
that I would listen to in these
subjects.
But he's a brilliant guy and he's a very
nice guy too.
And he's really missing,
misrepresented and in willfully.
So a lot.
I think it's sad because I think what's
missing between right and the left is
how much vit we we would probably agree
on and if we could just talk about
things rationally instead of
contentiously instead of getting into
these right versus left debates which
are just way too common where
everybody's on one side is trying to
diminish the person in their side and,
and,
and get angry and they're doing a lot of
these in front of big crowds,
which I think is also weird because then
you're playing to the crowd and I've
seen some things that Jordan did with
this Michael Eric Dyson guy with the guy
was literally wasn't looking at him.
He's looking at the crowd,
calling him a mean mad white man and
it's like I see these kinds of things
that people are doing.
It's just everyone's just digging their
heels in deeper on each side and instead
of looking at life like just having an
open conversation about things that are
troubling things where we could do
better things,
where society needs work or things.
Maybe where our perceptions are off and
maybe we could look at the other side
and look at each other or look at the
whole thing better and figure out a
better way around things instead of
doing that,
everybody's just right versus left and
right and deeper in the trenches and
harder and we've got to stop trump and I
hope we have a recession to stop trump
and people saying crazy shit crazy like
everybody's supposed to suffer so that
you can make one guy feel like he's
doing a bad job or just not the way to
approach it.
Like you've seen that.
What is that woman's name?
Maxine.
What is her name?
Maximum trump.
I
call her dark trump.
She says she's,
she's wild to interrupt people's meals
and draw a crowd and like,
you know,
and I guess it's in response to what is
the most disturbing policy was a
separate children from their parents.
People that are crossing the border,
but I think he didn't.
He decided to put a stop to that.
Then they decided to put a stop to that.
Did he sign something to put a stop to
that?
Well,
it's definitely scary if you're doing
that at the border.
They did,
but I don't know.
I read that it didn't do any change
anything.
Oh really?
Let's find out what the fuck that means.
We'll find out what would happen.
I know it's hard to do that and I,
I mean,
yeah.
How do you separate people from their
kids?
You gotta be you gotta be trying to send
some fucked up message to scare the shit
out of him so that'll keep them from
coming over.
This is the idea.
I guess if you tell them you're going to
take their kids away,
they probably won't even try and then.
But what about this say if like,
you know,
everybody's against like sex trafficking
and I'm not like what if one of those
people is that scenario and the kids too
afraid to say it.
I know that's like a maybe more of an
acute situation,
but in that case you'd be grateful that
you separated them at least to get each
other's point of view,
to know kind of what's a little bit more
what's going on.
Apparently that's like a huge issue.
Like apparently sex trafficking,
you know,
everybody's just bringing young women in
here to,
you know,
from other places for sex and I don't,
I don't see that much of it,
but apparently it's the biggest thing in
the world,
you know,
or it was last month.
Well,
there was something that was,
I don't know,
this is true either.
I'm giving Jamie a lot of work today.
Um,
there was a smart though,
right?
Um,
sex trafficking ring that was broken up
by ice and outside of it these people
were protesting ice because of what I,
they were like saying abolish ice.
But meanwhile ice was like stepping.
They didn't understand that when you're
doing,
what is it?
Emma's immigrations customs enforcement.
Ice stands for.
What they're doing is not just,
they're not just trying to stop people
from crossing over the border there also
busting in this case,
apparently it was a sex trafficking or
human trafficking ring.
I don't know if they were using them as
slaves or if they're using them as sex
slaves.
Well,
that's the thing.
Say if,
say if two truckloads of people coming
to America,
right.
And one is,
is,
um,
you know,
adults and children and another as
adults and children,
right.
And one of them are just actual family
members and one of them are sex,
you know,
adults,
mean men trying to bring in sex workers.
We,
that's.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do you know,
how do you not set,
you know,
like,
I know,
yeah,
you don't want to take a mother from a
kid or a father from a daughter,
but it's like,
how do you know what if and what if you
don't,
you know,
I don't know.
That is the problem with people coming
in.
If they're coming in illegally,
you have no idea who they are,
what they're doing.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's only one problem.
The other problem is people who are
criminals,
people who are violent
offenders,
you know,
people.
There's people that have gone back and
forth multiple times and got busted in
American wind up killing people.
That's happened many times.
Yeah.
They had that guy in San Francisco.
I remember that accidentally shot the
uh,
end up shooting the girl.
But yeah,
I mean it's,
you know,
I'm glad.
I mean,
I,
as much as it's hectic sometimes to
think about it and here about it,
I think it's also,
it's neat to be alive at a time when,
you know,
I'm challenged to think,
and I'm challenged to,
uh,
to,
to feel different ways and to hear
different voices and opinions about it
honestly.
Like I feel like we should have more of
a roll call in America.
Like you have to know who's here before
you can even,
you know,
like if you're teaching a classroom,
if you don't know who's in the class,
how can you even,
you know,
but it's
what they should do first and foremost
is legalized drugs.
And the reason being is that they're
getting across from organized crime and
it's building organized crime in Mexico
to a staggering degree.
The drugs are here.
People are selling these drugs,
period.
They're going to keep selling these
drugs.
You're not going to diminish the amount
of drugs.
You just not.
Yeah,
no one's ever been able to do it.
The drug wars and complete total
failure.
He Cope.
They love coke.
So make coke legal.
You would put a fucking halt to so much
and if you made coke,
legal people would buy pure coke.
You would it.
Would it be tested and you could give
people drug education because like
everybody knows.
Okay,
how many beers can you drink?
If you drink three beers,
you probably shouldn't drive a car
unless you're a giant,
you know,
like three beers.
You're probably over the legal limit.
Azure of Bayer,
right?
Let's just some seven foot tall
guerrilla type man.
We've got a lot of buy in a regular.
Like if you are a regular guy
disappears.
You should not drive.
Right.
So now stop and think like what is the
level for cocaine?
I don't know.
I don't do it.
I've never done it,
but I don't know what it is.
Like maybe we should know like you know,
you can't have three shots of Jack
Daniels and Dr. Okay.
But what,
what about,
what about speed?
I can take two lines of coke.
You should not be talking to people.
Yeah.
Business shouldn't be fucking calling an
architect.
Dude.
One of my buddies try to put all of his
fingers in his butt one time for you to
like an eight ball of coke.
How crazy is that?
Okay,
so good goal,
but a look and it's hard apparently to
do and it's nice to have a name for.
What was that called?
Fingers in your book called something.
It was like called a clapper.
The liberty bell or something.
Some crazy thing,
but I'm Jamie's googling it.
What is the term when you have all your
fingers in your butt?
I think that's called gopher hunting.
You have to be like,
how would you do that?
You'd have to be like lying on your back
with your legs,
bugs bunny style over your head.
You have to hook your left and then this
and to be super flexible.
Pull it off and you're going to.
The crazy part is,
and I've just thought about this a lot,
but I have thought about this for a
little bit.
You're going to start with your smallest
fingers and then you're going to be
stuck.
Those thumbs after
he going to be trying to get at the.
Yeah.
That's going to be the hard part.
You're going to rip your asshole.
Well that's the risk.
You take like an old balloon.
And that's why it's so exciting.
I think if there is no,
uh,
there has to be some risk of reward in
it from us.
Have slender fingers.
Well he was,
I mean look duties on that much cocaine
did.
I'll do.
And you know,
I used to.
That's the thing,
dude.
I got all fucked up,
you know,
I used to get cocaine and do it by
myself at home,
you know,
just to,
I don't know,
I wasn't doing that good just to have
some feelings.
And I remember,
dude,
I would order vests and shit off the
Internet.
I have kind of vessel all kinds,
like the kinds that we would wear if you
lived in boulder with them.
The downfield ones.
Patagonia.
Tell him no,
I've done.
I've gone.
That's a weird look.
You got the flower shirt with the puffy
vest.
Very common look.
But it's like,
what are we doing here?
Well,
I want to be warm,
but I want a lit,
a little bit of ventilation in my arm.
Just a little chill,
just a little bit of warmth around my
body though.
I liked my tour.
Showed to be warm.
I'm talking old.
I'm talking to all kinds,
bro.
I wouldn't get the leather.
I would get the ones with the bead.
I mean I have like A.
Honestly,
I've probably about 30 vests at home.
Well,
I vest.
Why was that the thing that you would
order on cocaine?
It was just something I liked to do.
Belt buckles.
You have any preposterous,
like some of that light up different
colors and shit.
He like.
Yeah,
I'm going out with this.
One of my buddies had a belt.
I said Pussy only on it.
Oh Nice.
Yeah,
that guy's gay,
but 100 percent gay.
They'll push you.
What about you fucking go,
Bro,
you don't want to do what?
I get pushy.
You know,
what do you do?
I'll show you both.
Take your pants off.
And so it was a blue suit first put on
it.
Be careful.
He's like,
yeah,
I've got a lady a tattooed on my ass,
so love it.
Let's push it.
I got vulva tattooed on my back in a,
in old English letters,
bro.
I love puts you so much.
I had my ass hole turned into a pussy.
Fuck it.
It feels just like the real thing,
but eight and a half of your fingers in
it,
bro.
Do you stem cells broke?
I got some new stem cells.
Do I got these new stem cells used on my
ass.
So,
um,
but uh,
but that guy,
yeah.
How do you transition?
I don't know,
but they got Jordan Peterson was super
cool man.
What did you guys talk about when you
listen to any of this stuff before you
had them on?
Yeah,
I listened to your episode with them
extra from the day before and I listened
to 'em and I'd been listening to his
book.
So that's where I was.
And I listened to the debate of the munk
debates of the ones where the guy called
him a bad white man.
I was like,
this so silly,
but I found him to be in this just a.
He just seemed like the pure.
He seemed completely pure and whatever,
you know,
he believed,
I think that in helping people,
like,
because I talked to him about like did
he start to feel like famous,
you know,
like because people are really
gravitating towards and he just felt it
genuinely seemed that he felt just good
for people.
He Won.
He was happy
to be helping others and that like,
it didn't seem like he had any ego in
it.
He,
um,
he definitely does like to help people,
but he also feels a responsibility
because of his knowledge to explain what
he thinks is a problem with certain
types of behavior,
certain laws and one of them that got
them in trouble or got him
controversial,
got a lot of controversy attached to it
was the compelled speech laws for
transgender people.
The use of a compelled pronouns,
meaning Canada.
Yeah.
So if you decided that you weren't going
to be a he or a she,
you could make up a number of different
names and they would be legally
compelled to use those names.
And some people are arguing that's not
what it says.
And then he was saying,
no,
it's a,
it's a human rights violation if you
don't follow along with that,
like this is,
this is compelled speech and this is
dangerous because this is why this is
what it leads to.
And then there's all these people are
debating with them.
But then when you got a chance to see
his,
with him debating these points with
these various intellectuals,
including like gender studies,
teachers and Shit,
you got to see like,
oh this,
this is a crazy idea.
Like these,
these people that think that you should
have like 78 different gender pronouns.
And then it's,
it's tantamount to violence to not use
someone's preferred pronoun.
And you're like,
oh,
you're crazy.
Oh this is a mad person who wants the
world to be different.
So you want all these new laws attached
to whether or not someone calls them and
he or she and they're getting some
traction with it.
What is weird in New York,
New York City,
I think it's the landlords and it might
be employers my,
but I think I'm pretty sure it's
landlords.
They are compelled to use your preferred
pronoun,
so if your landlord decides to call you
a different thing,
like if you say a machine now,
and he's like,
fuck you knew you when you were theo,
Theo.
See what that law is.
Uh,
uh,
compelled gender pronouns,
law,
New York City.
But,
but people are like,
wait a minute,
how many do I have to know?
Which ones do I have to agree with you
start?
Because there's a ton of them.
Now they're literate is 78 different
gender pronouns.
You know what I'm fine like,
I know they would,
uh,
you know,
for awhile it was like,
people in certain areas they don't want
to build transgender bathrooms.
It's like because there's nine people in
this town and we've seen everybody's
Dick,
like,
nobody.
We don't have any.
You can't change all these zoning laws
for peak,
for when there's not even someone
present in some of these areas.
I think in some bad ways they're making
people not be accepting of transgender
people that they may meet at some point
by creating all of this,
this,
this rhetoric or whatever it is,
this conversation.
It's like some people are already fed up
and they've never even met someone like
this and so then they're going to have
weird.
They're going to have already like
contentious views when they do meet
someone just because they've heard so
much background noise that it's
problematic.
You know when not.
That's certainly
possible.
It's also possible that people will be
scared of the backlash so they won't use
transphobic language anymore.
The problem with that is you're not
encouraging empathy.
You're encouraging fear.
You're encouraging fear of not following
the standard line of behavior and speech
and that's where people have a problem
with it.
It's like the real way to do it is to
promote empathy,
to say like,
look,
these people like this,
guys born in the wrong body became a
woman who went through the surgery,
let him use the women's room like why
not?
And if they're a bad person,
judged that bad person on each
individual basis.
Now when you're talking about children,
that's what people are scared of,
that you know you're going to have some
creep who pretends he's a woman so he
can get in the girls room and he's gonna
molest children.
Like those are those worst case
scenarios.
Yeah,
those are terrible worst case scenarios,
but what?
How often is that going to happen?
How do we protect that?
How do we prevent that from happening?
Those are the questions,
but what for the vast majority of the
people that become trans,
do you really think that they're going
to molest people?
I don't think they are.
You can't judge the vast majority based
on a few.
That's just like the same logic that
says people shoot up people with guns,
so we should take everyone's guns away.
That's crazy to know.
The vast majority of people with guns
don't shoot people.
The vast majority of people were trans.
They don't want to hurt anybody.
Then that's all they're trying to do is
just get along and be who they are.
This is a complex subject.
At the end,
the danger is when people are scared,
they're scared or bullied into agreeing
with one side of the other side because
then then shit gets weird because then
it becomes a battle but becomes a battle
instead of an opportunity.
Yeah.
Discussion and opportunity to.
To enforce and encourage compassion like
that.
It can be done both ways.
Yeah.
I think the opera,
but to look at these people like,
look,
they just hook.
Why do you care if someone wants to be a
girl?
Why do you care if she wants to be a
guy?
Why do you care?
Like let them do it.
Let them be free.
Let them be there themselves.
Just like let it do tattoo his face.
Let let what do whatever you want,
man.
As long as you're not fucking people
over and you're not hurting people,
you know out there robbing people and
stealing from people and murdering
people.
As long as that's not happening.
Do whatever you want.
What should be our approach?
This stuff that should be one of our.
That should be someone in the bill of
rights or something or a new what?
New.
A new amendment should be something in
there where we think about the why,
why,
why we have a problem,
and how we address the problem.
As soon as you address the problem of
force,
force forward is forced in return,
you're going to get forced back.
People are going to get,
they're going to want to get ramped up
just as much to attack you is.
You attack them and then you going back
and forth left and right and it becomes
fucking chaos.
And that's what we have right now.
When you see the difference between Fox
News and CNN and the right and the left
and everybody digs their heels in bad.
Fuck,
it's,
it's not,
it's not helpful.
It's not helpful.
And there's also a bunch of people that
profit off of this,
this battle and dispute.
Okay?
No New York City did not just introduce
it,
$250,000,
fine for any incorrect use of gender
pronouns,
but they did for some use of gender
pronouns.
I think the question
misinterpretation of a guideline that's
already existed,
uh,
there was a blog post that got written
in the New York Post reported on it.
There was an updated or a change in the
guidelines,
but it's not supposed to be for like an
incorrect or ms dot misuse of it.
What is it supposed to be for harassment
and discrimination and things like that.
Okay.
So regardless of individual sex assigned
at birth anatomy,
gender,
medical history,
appearance or the sex indicated on the
individual's identification.
Okay.
The raw requires employers and covered
entities to use an individual's
preferred name,
Pronoun and title,
Eg,
Mrs. Or Mrs. Regardless of the
individual sex assigned at birth.
So that's it.
Okay.
These guidelines as noted by the
commission can impose penalties of up to
$250,000 for violations that are the
result of willful,
wanton or malicious conduct.
So that seems like they're saying that
it is true.
There are.
That is.
So there is a law,
but there's a commission.
It's not just like you can't just say it
and someone's going to find you.
It has to go through a long,
lengthy court process and they're not
just finding people like businesses and
like.
Exactly.
I get it still slippery.
This is all going to.
Can you imagine the GE?
All this is going to do is create a ton
of lawsuits.
Yeah.
Just because it's a commission like that
that might even be worse that you're
bringing it into.
Like you have to sit in front of a bunch
of experts who have to decide whether or
not you.
You missed gendered.
Someone stop.
Like,
it's crazy.
It's crazy to miss.
Just look,
if someone's an asshole,
you're an asshole.
Like what if,
what if you're a Jew and someone calls
you a Kike?
Can they get fined $250,000.
How does that work?
Well,
no.
Right,
but that's an offensive term for a
Jewish person.
Right.
So if you,
if you brought that to court,
how would that work?
I don't think you'd get people.
It's commission though.
Yeah.
That would be like a business being
brought.
They're not like just a person,
right?
Yeah,
like landlords.
It was one of them that they brought up.
Like if you decided that you will be
Jamie still,
but now you're jamming the woman.
I'm like,
the fuck Outta here,
Jamie,
you're a dude.
GimMe my money,
but it's like a wouldn't date
if that was the case it was and I wanted
an apartment that you were offering and
you wouldn't give me the apartment for
that reason
or we work together in some sort of way
and I'm discriminating against you at
work.
So it feel like so many.
It just seems like a ground for so many
lawsuits.
What I find is if somebody is an addict
to somebody,
if somebody's calling somebody a name or
something these days with so many camera
phones and so many things,
usually it gets brought up pretty quick.
If somebody is racist these days,
like really devout in their core
and they like it gets brought out pretty
fucking quick.
Not always though.
Not always.
I'm sure some people get away with it.
Well,
you know how you learn.
You know how I learned like a in the
area I grew up in not to be racist.
You'd hear somebody say something to
somebody else that they shouldn't say
and they got their ass whooped and then
they learn,
not they.
I mean it was a weird way to learn it,
but you learned,
you learned.
It would be nice if people could learn
another way to realize how stupid it is
to just be racist.
Yeah.
There's plenty of ways you should judge
individuals like based on their actions
and what they've done,
how they're treating other people,
how you know whether or not they're
doing things that are illegal or immoral
or unethical.
That's as an individual,
but as soon as you're doing it based on
where they can't control right there,
what they're,
what they look like,
where they were born,
what part of the world they're from.
That's just fucking stupid.
It's just a stew.
It's you're,
you're,
you're judging people on something.
I have zero control over.
You don't have any control of your
color.
That's crazy and yeah,
there's people that are still doing
that,
that are still living in that space.
Then it's.
I mean,
it is something that I think some of it
will just take more time,
but I think eventually something will be
eradicated it.
I think it's beige powers my thing.
We're all going to be beige,
Bro.
You know what I'm saying?
We're three January.
Regeneration from all being based thing.
So you don't know.
No,
not because of places like England and
Scotland and Ireland where it's always
rainy.
You're going to just kinda get a massive
amount of white people in those spots no
matter what.
There's no sun.
Even White Brown people that moved
there,
five,
six,
seven generations in this type Pale
enough.
Brendan Schaub.
See he said he was from England.
That's what it.
Is.
It really black dude from Manga?
I don't think he does.
He just forgets things.
A black guy from England like 500 years
ago,
his whole fan was probably black and
then over time,
over time they just turned into white
people.
Just like every other person that moved
to England,
right?
Every fucking human being came out of
Africa.
One hundred percent.
That's the origin of the species.
We came from Africa.
We branched out into the world and we
got to places like Scotland where it
never fucking never sunny and we got
bleached out.
He believed God,
they turned into like a solar panels for
vitamin D at this to soak up that
vitamin D.
Yeah,
because if you're black,
like you have so much Melanin,
Congo black,
you got a dark skin color that's just
awesome for sun,
but it's terrible when there's no sun,
like how are you getting your vitamin D
dot?
Even if you hug a black person,
I feel like your skin feels a little bit
kind of like more moist.
You know what I'm saying?
They use cocoa butter.
Remember ashy Larry?
Oh Dude.
We had to do in our neighborhood.
His brothers set him on fire and his
whole leg was asked.
She just do booboo.
Tyson and he is.
Same thing.
It's different kind of ashy along.
Oh yeah,
she's just dry skin,
but sometimes I feel a little bit of
African like in my course and I was a
lay in bed at night and just pretend I
was in Africa.
She ever get your blood tested
to see what you are.
Yeah.
I didn't look at the results yet.
We didn't look at the results and it
scared.
I'm.
Maybe I'm a little bit nervous,
but what you might be.
I don't want to be French.
That's what I don't want to be honest
with you.
I think your French French a little bit.
Yeah.
I think you've got 13 percent.
Don't laugh about that.
Jamie.
How come you don't want to be French?
I've all things.
What's wrong with that?
Why would that bother you?
Even a little bit.
Just they made great wine,
great painters who crave wine.
They complain a lot.
Apparently they liked to fuck.
Really?
That's the word that French people just
like to fuck and they think that the way
we handle things is stupid.
They have affairs like openly,
publicly,
the French,
a little bit.
Politicians,
they of course they cheat.
They're all fucking animals over there.
It just drew and that toxo plasma
apparently was running rapid through
France.
Really?
Is it toxo plasma is that thing that you
get from cats?
Get it and they get it from rats and
it's a,
it's a parasite that gets into human
brains and it affects humans and it
makes people a little bit more reckless.
Like rabies kind of a light.
No,
not rabies.
More like a,
like slightly drunk all the time.
And uh,
this toxo plasma.
Apparently there was one point in time
40 percent of the franchise of France
was infected with toxo plasma.
Yeah.
See if you find that that's true.
It must have been a fuck fest.
I Beth fuck fest.
Wild and loose.
Yeah.
You Got to pee.
They think that there's a direct
correlation between the high levels of
infestation and the behavioral changes
that the population in Pensacola,
what?
Rats and stuff.
No,
of this talkshow plastic suppliers and
probably 50 million people in this
country have it.
You get it from cat shit or from if you
live in a farm,
like you step on the field and it gets
in your skin.
Like maybe cats had been shitting all
over the place,
or a dog will eat something that you
know,
some cat shit,
wouldn't you get shit and you're around
the dog.
Two thousand 12 analysis from France are
an estimated 43 percent of the people
carrying toxoplasmosis.
Gandhi concluded that men with a latent
infection tend to be more dogmatic,
less confident,
more jealous,
less impulsive,
and more orderly than infected men.
Infected women seem warmer,
more conscientious,
more persistent,
more insecure,
and more sanctimonious.
Whoa,
dude.
I'll get a six pack for the ladies then.
Huh?
That sounds crazy.
Is that that 43 percent of people carry
it?
Jesus Christ.
That's a large number of human beings
infected by something that changes
behavior or at least leads to trends
that are different and and noticeable.
More dogmatic,
less confident,
less confident is interesting that gone
die.
Toxoplasmosis gone die.
Associations of having antibodies to the
parasite with bipolar,
suicidal
behavior,
even optimistic disposition,
possibly related to the parasites effect
on dopamine.
So it gets into your body and then you
just have it for life.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
it is sexually transmitted.
It must be.
Then that's a good question.
That's a very good question.
I don't know if 43 percent of people
have it.
I can't imagine that half of the
population to stepped on a,
you know,
fucking.
Well,
I think that's a good question.
That's a good question.
But I think there's a lot of feral cats
around.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
I think when there's places like El
Gato.
Yeah.
We got a lot of feral cats running
around gratitude.
They have that whole movie.
But that animal,
that was a chef.
Yup.
And what it does to the rats is that
makes them get hard ons when they smell
cat piss.
Is that really?
Yup.
It rewires their sexual reward system.
So the testes in large,
when they smell cat piss.
No,
they get hard.
So it gets at a fucking.
A neighbor like that dated.
This guy will always with pregnancy.
Say that again.
It gets them through pregnancy to the
child.
Woof,
woof.
There you go.
Know 43 percent is a high number.
That's like,
it's a lot of people.
It's 43 out of 100 people do 3 billion
people on the planet.
Two billion people have it as 43 percent
of those tested in that study and that's
all the people that get tested.
Who the fuck I've never been tested.
You've been tested?
No.
How many of you have been tested?
That's a rough estimate,
man.
They don't fucking know.
I bet it's a lot higher.
I bet.
As a lot of people that have it.
Yeah.
Shit in the blood,
dude.
I probably got it.
We had a Dr Robert Sapolsky and the
podcast.
We did one with him.
He's an expert in it and he's got a
bunch of lectures and speeches on it and
he said that when he was a resident then
he heard about a guy who found out that
a disproportionate number of motorcycle
accidents were attributed to people that
were on this toxo plasma.
Really?
Yeah.
That they.
That they got this infection and it was
causing them to do stupid shit on
motorcycles and crash.
I would hate that man.
It's hard enough to ride a motorcycle
and then they have like,
you know,
just to be being led astray by rare
disease in your brain one.
And I wonder if it varies.
Right?
I wonder if the Toxoplasma that they get
in Paris has the same exact response was
the one that they get in South America.
The America.
That is a bunch of variations.
Yeah.
Oh,
see,
that's what I'm talking about.
There's different ones.
A Long Island has a lot of Jesus Christ.
Fuck,
see,
I bet the.
What is this though?
This seemed like.
What is it?
Well,
it's parasites.
Parasites,
parasites exist in so many animals.
They hitch rides and then that's their
ecosystem.
Our ecosystem is to be on planet earth.
Their ecosystem is to be in planet feel
Vaughn and they just get inside of you.
Have parasites ever changed?
Like the kind of the course of history?
Is that what happened with the plague or
is that a different thing?
No,
the plagues a different thing,
but they probably could change the
course of history.
Have they really changed that many
people's behavior?
If you think about Paris or France,
they're talking about 43 percent of the
people have this infection and the irony
of parasites.
How crazy is that?
That's crazy.
It's Paris site.
What if they have.
Could you imagine a little French
fucking berets?
We Lee.
I'm going to change your behavior a
little.
You'll go to stupid American.
The craziest one man is this aquatic
worm.
It climbs inside of grasshoppers.
Body grows and the grasshoppers body,
and then it tells the grasshopper to
commit suicide.
Oh my God.
So it gets the grasshopper to jump into
the water and then once the grasshopper
gets in the water,
then it bursts out of its body.
Oh,
it's like Pinocchio meets.
I'm alien.
Have you seen the movie alien?
Sigourney weaver.
It is like Pinocchio.
It's like the bottom of the whale,
right in the belly of the whale.
Yeah.
That movie alien with Sigourney Weaver.
Probably my favorite science fiction
movie of all time.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I would say if I had to pick one science
fiction horror movie that was like the
one.
I'll say that alien.
It's kind of cornball.
When you watched the special effects now
though?
Yeah.
Not as scary.
There's some space stuff that you like,
oh,
okay.
This is 1978.
Forget different times and even 1980
man,
you know,
it's a corny.
That's crazy.
Hot hades or being tall and she had
curly hair.
I remember thinking I'm strong.
Confident.
Sexy.
Yes.
You were fucking neck like you think you
couldn't choke her out?
Yeah.
Like if she was.
She was such a powerful woman.
Like this isn't a woman that needs a
man.
She liked you.
It's like,
oh.
She's like,
I'm worthy.
I'm worthy of her.
Like she drove a van,
but because she had fucking business to
do.
Yeah.
I think we should have like an old land
cruiser.
Look at Toyota.
FJ 41 of those ones.
Yeah.
She'd be like an archeologist or some
shit,
right?
Yeah.
She had a fucking pickax and what?
She was in Avatar.
Right in.
What is this?
Oh,
that's the alien.
Took it that.
That's too.
Is that a raccoon?
What does that.
So it's a kid.
This little kid hanging onto her bro.
I love that.
That was alien.
Alien Two's not my favorite because it
was like,
wait a minute,
why is it so easy to kill them all of a
sudden,
so easy to kill them because there's so
many of them.
Like alien one.
That fucking thing was like it was
thinking it was.
It was.
It was ahead of you every step of the
way.
Alien too.
They just became like clumsy and
bumbling and shoot them and then there's
another one around the corner.
Shoot that one too.
It's like,
okay.
Did I remember a Arachnophobia had me
shook.
Remember that one when the spider has
gotten that duplex,
brother shook me to the core to see this
one is like way deep into the future.
Like the first one was in the seventies,
[inaudible] and they're still doing them
now.
That's what's crazy.
To ready to bang out new alien movies.
Now the Predator coming out,
they'd have a new Predator coming up.
They do hilarious.
Why not make some money?
Yeah,
that's true.
That kind of stuff is fun.
It's probably fun.
I can't believe Brennan.
Siobhan,
Italian.
Would you say it was British English?
Yeah.
Hmm.
That came from Africa through England a
thousand years ago.
His people did.
Oh,
I know.
Over time.
White.
That's why they call him big brown.
Oh really?
No.
Just made all that.
Oh Dang.
I was going on here.
I thought he seemed like he seemed
pretty white to me when I see a giant
white dude.
Yeah.
He loved.
He always has.
He as the best disposition doesn't
break.
He just loves to laugh.
Do you can take it out on.
He just hated on dudes.
Get Jealous.
Do you ever get jealous?
But do you think.
And also he says stupid shit sometimes,
but do you think he feels that he.
I feel like he has a special gift where
you can kind of,
especially if you're a buddy,
like you can kind of joke with him and
he loved,
like he just,
he knows that you love him.
You know he's a great guy.
He brushes it off.
He's got a great attitude.
Like if more people had his attitude
about dealing with life's problems,
we'd have a happier world.
He knows how to let things roll right
off his back.
He's big.
He's a smart guy,
man.
I always like being around him.
Yeah,
man.
He gets a lot of hate online.
It's interesting.
Yeah,
I think it,
but I think as guys that are jealous
because when I go on the road like I
just went to Bakersfield recently,
which is.
Can we just say it's like the best
people ever came out there.
Feels fucking amazing.
I felt like I felt like hulk Hogan Bro.
People came out.
People were crying,
someone's sacrifice,
their cousins.
Some guy came out of the closet like all
they wanted it all to happen at the
show.
You know?
People were giving me recipes.
People were donating blood thing.
Man,
it ain't that far.
It's an hour and a half hour and 40
minutes.
How long does it take to get to
Bakersfield from ela?
Two hours.
Two hours Max.
It should be the new capital,
Bro.
It's not a bad spot.
And the people are Super Nice.
Pretty diverse.
I mean,
yeah,
it was cool,
man.
I really liked it.
Although I did turn my sink on.
It's Brown.
Shit was fucking flying out of the sink.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
I've made an instagram video of it.
I was like,
Bakersfield,
what the fuck is going on with your
water man?
To say good,
because you know their high school,
their mascot.
It's called the drillers.
The team name because they're oil
drillers.
Do you know that that whole area is
where there will be blood that no.
Daniel Day,
Lewis Lewis movie.
I love that guy.
That's an amazing movie too.
So good that there will be blood is
about that whole area.
That's where there's apparently.
Look at that.
Is My water coming out of my fucking
sick.
Did you drink any?
Oh yeah,
dude.
Crazy noises out brown water
and the word says you already brushed
your teeth.
That's the crazy part too.
I hate when that happens because you
don't know it first.
Ooh,
it's funky.
Definitely seems like a malt,
but I think that I was staying at our
super old hotel,
like real from the 18 hundreds.
They like redid it downtown.
Yeah.
What is it called?
I think it might have stayed at the ace
hotel,
the NSA Godrej.
I didn't tell people where I stood
because I didn't want to be mean to the
hotel.
The Padre hotel.
I think of this as the old place.
Yes.
I think that's it.
I think it was nice.
Had a nice.
It was nice in there.
It was nice restaurant.
Elevator.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's just.
They got some old ass pipes.
Clean those pipes on.
Something is going wrong and I was
staying there.
So what if.
What if I took a mouthful that drank it?
What did he died?
What if I was just shitting all over
myself for the rest of the day and I had
to cancel my shows.
Oh,
how about that?
People would be furious.
Angry.
Rightly so.
They shouldn't be furious.
Do.
Do you think you'll die one day or not?
I'm not trying to make you think about
it.
I'm pretty sure that's how the world.
That's how the road goes.
Yeah.
You're born and then you die.
What?
What do you think?
Don't know man.
Crush it.
Doesn't think you die.
Yeah.
I think.
I think he's just drunk.
Yeah,
that could be it too.
You didn't have a shirt on,
dude,
you get to put a shirt on and decide if
you're going to die or.
No,
he goes,
prove it,
prove it.
Oh boy.
We have to base this on what we know
about people now.
I know the people you used to be alive
and now they're not.
So what happened to them?
Are they faking it?
You know,
like you.
Will you be sad if you die,
you think?
I think I'll be dead,
Bro.
Yeah.
What about you?
I'd be sad if you died.
Oh,
thank you.
I'd be sad if you died too.
Thanks man.
Um,
I would be worried about the end of your
life.
Yeah,
I worry about him in a sense.
It makes you really wonder then what,
what is my time mean?
What does your timing like?
What's important to you in this life
right now?
Um,
I think probably being,
just feeling more okay with myself
probably and trying to have maybe help
other people being more okay with
yourself.
Like what?
What bothers you about yourself?
Uh,
I just wish I just felt more comfortable
in my own skin a lot of times,
you know,
because I feel like I'm be able to be
more effective as a person if I could
just kind of get not toil in some of my
own,
you know,
the small self worth issues or like lack
of confidence at times,
you know,
I wish I could trust my instincts and I
wish my instincts were like better
calibrated so that I knew when I was
what if I was doing like,
okay,
in good stuff,
then my insides like told me,
you're being okay.
You don't have to worry.
You know,
there's a lot of things going on there,
right?
One of them,
the big one is almost always from your
childhood,
almost feelings of lack of worth and
self worth come from that feeling as
you're developing,
as you're growing up.
Yeah.
Feel like you're not loved or you're not
appreciated or you're,
you're criticized too much.
You feel like you're a loser and really
be concise.
Psychologically can be very hard to
shake.
And even as people get older,
they still,
they still cling to this thought that
they're a piece of shit because they are
a piece of shit in someone's eyes when
they were eight or 10.
That's a real problem with people,
man.
And that's one of the reasons why when
someone gets bullied when they're young,
it can be so devastating because it's
happening when you're in high school or
junior high school and it becomes a
defining moment for you.
Yet I was scared as one kid really also
about this one kid,
one of the reasons why I got into
wrestling this kid,
uh,
like we had this confrontation and a
locker room and I didn't think were
going to fight.
Like I was just totally bluffing.
I don't know what,
what I said or what he said,
I don't remember.
But I do remember him getting me in a
headlock,
throwing me on the ground and then
leaning like he was gonna Punch me in
the face.
But deciding not to and I didn't know
what to do.
I had no,
no martial arts skills.
No nothing.
I haven't.
I'd never wrestled anybody before.
I didn't know anything,
so there's nothing in you that is like a
new reaction,
panicked and no idea what to do.
And I think and I thought,
shit,
I didn't think he was going to do that
and now here I am on my back.
I'm traveling,
God dammit.
I got to learn how to wrestle.
I got to learn some martial arts or
something.
So then I started taking karate and then
I started taking wrestling like right
after that.
But I avoided that kid every time I saw
him.
When I see him on the other side of
school,
it looks through the breezeway and I've
always knew where he was around.
I got to go around.
I don't want to see that guy that threw
me on the ground and could have punched
me in the face.
It was almost like more humiliating that
he did,
could have punched me in the face,
but he didn't.
But that bullying and that guy doing
that,
to me,
that fear of like being I'm just
helpless,
made me get into martial arts.
I was like,
fuck this.
Like I gotta figure out how to fight.
I don't want this to happen to me
anymore to do you see as the benefit.
It was a lucky situation to look.
He didn't beat me up.
It could've been way worse.
It was not that big a deal.
It was an easy school to go to.
Like my school wasn't hard.
Even though there was some criminals
that were in that school,
like some kids that get shipped into.
There was some bad kids and one of them
got charged with murder,
like right after graduating.
We were like,
whoa.
Our friend Kevin,
we knew this dude and he killed
somebody,
but like,
whoa.
Yeah.
Everybody was like,
whoa.
That guy killed somebody.
I think he was one year older than me.
Yeah.
He murdered somebody like right after
high school.
Yeah,
there's a kid.
We knew he was on the football team.
We knew him.
And then do you ever think he would
murder somebody?
He was a tough guy.
He's a scary guy for sure.
Like a powerhouse of a person,
like a tank.
I didn't know him well though,
but I,
you know,
I'd say hi to them,
but it's one of those things where when
something like that happens to you and
for me again,
it was very minor,
just I was just scared of this guy now
he didn't do anything to me.
Horrible.
Just threw me on the ground.
So when somebody's going to beat your
brains,
I mean if somebody could hold you down
like that I could do,
could have beat my face and I wouldn't
have been able to do shit.
Are you grateful in a weird way that he
didn't or not grateful?
Looking back on her for sure,
but it was enough.
He just let me know.
I was,
you know,
I don't know what I said.
I'm in a said something stupid.
He might've said something stupid and
wanted me to back down and I didn't.
So he just grabbed me,
threw me on the ground.
But the fact that he,
that he did it and could do it led me to
make one of the biggest decisions of my
whole life is getting involved in
martial arts.
I just didn't want that feeling anymore
of like if someone talks like gives me a
hard time,
I want to be the one who can decide
whether or not this gets violent or who
gets hurt.
I don't want to leave that into some
stranger's hand,
so it might be a fucking psychopath if
it's in my hands.
No one's getting hurt.
We're going to be finally,
there's a video of Matt Serra from
yesterday.
Matt Serra,
there was a drunk and altercation with
some fucking dude in a food court.
Matt Serra who is a Brazilian Jujitsu
black belt,
who at one point in time when he was
competing,
he was one of the best presented to to
artists in the world.
Then on top of that,
he fought mma,
knocked out George St.
Pierre won the welterweight title and
he's got some dude on the ground and
he's just saying,
calm down,
calm down because I'm gonna fuck you up.
I'm going to fuck.
But it's hilarious to watch like,
look at this look good,
play good and play the volume.
He's like,
I'm going to break your fucking face.
He's holding his wrist.
I love how you have the shirt on the
guy's face.
He's like,
calm down,
calm down.
It's like he's putting a crying baby to
sleep,
and so the security guard comes over and
says,
let him go.
He goes,
okay,
you're going to control them.
You going to control them.
Are you going to control knowing that?
Are you ready to control them?
Like he's not standing up and he's fat?
I'll tell
you something.
Mad.
Sarah's one of the nicest fucking guys
on the planet earth.
If he has to do this to you in a
restaurant and she's a restaurant,
he's got full mount on you.
You fucked up.
You fucked up dude.
But see,
you're way better off with Matt Serra in
that position.
Then that drunk dude on some guy who
doesn't know how to fight.
It could be that too.
That drunk dude could just be a real
mean violent person who wants to beat
someone up if he gets him down.
So if there's guys like you who aren't
into that.
So you found getting into martial arts,
I really kind of lead you in a way where
you felt more confident in case things
got into an uncomfortable situation that
you would be okay.
Yeah.
Well look,
you're always.
You're always going to be nervous in
life when something's important,
whether it's going on stage or something
difficult to do.
Difficult things make you nervous.
It's like there's an anticipation.
There's an understanding of the
difficulty of something you're about to
pursue and whether or not you're going
to fall short or whether or not you're
going to succeed.
That shit makes people nervous,
but the physical confrontation,
nervousness is a bad one.
That's like dad is
a paralyzing fear when the fear of being
bullied or being hurt and you can't do
anything about it.
That devastates people,
that puts them in a deep,
deep depression.
So it's really important to I think.
I think every young man should learn how
to fight.
I think there would be way less fights
because of it and I don't think you have
to be a mean person to learn martial
arts.
I think it's a skill and I think you
learn it and then once you start getting
good at it,
it started actually starts actually
becoming fun and the people who practice
it with you,
you become close with you,
don't.
You don't hate the people that you're
practicing fighting with.
They become some of your closest friends
and I think it's just a big.
It's a giant confidence boost to know
that you can do something difficult and
get better at it.
That's,
I think,
just that alone.
It has massive benefits for people.
Yeah,
you know,
I can sense that meant I remember
watching a video a couple years ago
actually if you like getting a belt or
something,
they gave you a,
some Dojo or I'm not sure what the
correct terminology is.
It might've been probably watching when
I got my black belt.
Yeah,
maybe that was it.
But anyway.
Yeah,
like all,
like there was a lot of guys around
just.
And I know that Coco does it,
Joe,
he does it.
He loves it and he said,
why don't you do it?
You're a strapping man.
You talked to Eddie about going to do it
one day,
do it,
so he said,
uh,
he said,
yeah,
come down one day and he'll,
you know,
get me into like,
one of the beginners classes.
I think I need to do it.
Fuck yeah.
Could make me feel a little bit more,
um,
know,
like you said,
some of them that just a,
I don't know,
some.
And especially like if people get
bullied and then they don't have like a
brother or they don't have a friend or
they don't even have somebody to go talk
to,
to be like,
oh man.
And then their blooded,
he'd be like,
oh,
it's okay.
You know,
like that seat that's,
that can make you know.
Then that person gets stuck inside
themselves just feeling like,
you know,
like they're not going to be okay.
No,
no.
It's terrifying.
And then everywhere you go,
you're,
you're just scared of running into this
guy.
Yeah,
very,
very bad.
You know,
she'd get into tenements,
do it.
It's a fucking natural animal
inclination to pick on the weak,
you know,
only humans realize it and stop it.
And actually tell people not to do it
and understand the effect that it has on
the people that do it,
but every animal does it.
Dogs do it,
chickens do it.
Chickens have a pecking order.
They fuck with one chicken and then they
all decided,
oh,
let's fuck with this bitch.
And they all attack her for no reason.
It's weird man.
And you've seen it.
Everybody's seen dogs do it.
One dog will blow up and the other dog,
the dog will cower.
And then they decided the pecking order.
I mean,
and then that dog will always go near
that dog and fuck with them and growl at
them.
Maybe bite his year or something like
that.
Yeah,
it's a weird thing that animals figured
out how to make sure that the only ones
that get to breed are the ones that are
confident and powerful and can overcome
problems.
Okay.
And one of the problems is other mating
viable males that want to meet with the
women that you want to meet with,
like with this fucking giraffe.
They wound up killing those three other
drafts.
This guy just was like,
fuck these bitches coming up.
I'm going to smash my head into these
drafts.
Stop them.
You ain't fucking these girls when you
get older.
Fuck you bitch,
and this is just a natural inclination
that animals have to find the weak and
force it out and we don't have it.
Well we do.
We did have it.
Fortunately we haven't less now.
I said,
well,
we realize because of communication,
right?
We realized that there's devastating
effects in this.
Then we have loving and caring
communities and we have compassion that
you shouldn't do that,
but there's an inclination that people
have to pick on the weak and attack the
weak.
It's very.
It's very disturbing,
but it's also very logical in terms of
like biology,
right?
We're trying to make it difficult for
males to breed.
It's not like we have very few people
and we're trying to make as many people
as we get.
No,
no,
no.
It's like the highest status mails and
the dominant males are competing against
these other males in order to be able to
breed with,
you know,
whatever lizards are fucking wolves or
any,
any in any species.
The high status male wolf is the one who
gets to breed with the the choice
females and this is how they're carrying
their genes on.
It happens in deer,
it happens in elk,
it happens in all these different
animals and they fight.
I mean the reason why these,
these antlers.
Elk.
Yeah.
Those are for fighting.
That's all there for.
They actually lose those fucking things.
After they're done breeding,
really.
They fall off and they grow back again
the next year.
That is the fastest body part growth
known to man is elk antlers and that,
I mean when you look at those,
it looks like it would take 70 years to
grow the grow those motherfuckers at a
couple of months and then it'll grow
bigger next year up until a point,
sometime around like age nine or 10.
Sometimes they taper off and they start
to decline.
As they get older,
their their antlers actually become
smaller and smaller,
but for the most part as the.
That's one of the reasons why people
want to shoot a big male is because that
male with big antlers,
that male spread his genetics for many,
many years.
So his genes are will long passed on.
He's probably a bread with dozens of
females.
Oh,
I see.
So if it has a,
it's obviously been alive a long time
and it has that family treat is hanging
out of the front of its head.
Exactly.
And you know,
okay,
this thing is already.
It's already prospered.
Yeah.
And the idea also is that to only shoot
those mails,
those,
those high status,
big males,
it's actually better for the population
because then the younger males get a
chance to become older because they'll
kill them.
They killed young males.
If a young male gets fucking frisky and
he thinks he's a bad ass,
the big old bowl,
fuck him up.
And one of the ways they fuck them up as
their antlers are longer so they can get
the young one when the young one can't
get him.
Nothing Ms Dot Kinda Kinda evil,
but your,
your weapons are dictated by your age.
It's really weird,
right?
And your strength and like how,
how,
how much vitality you have.
That's what grows your antlers out in
that.
Fascinating that.
That's how it all
that it's all put together like that.
It is fucked up and they bullied the
shit out of those young bowls.
They chase them away.
You get no pussy.
Those,
those young bulls are,
they call them satellite bowls there.
So horny.
Are they hanging on the outside of the
blues?
That's why they're susceptible to
hunters because hunters like make a cow
calling.
They make this go like,
hey,
who wants to fuck one to fuck?
And then they get shot.
Yeah.
So they get.
That's one of the things about elk
hunting that's so interesting,
so that you call them in actually make
sounds to try to bring them towards you.
So they think they're going to get some
pussy or they think there's a fight.
That's the other thing you do.
You make a bugle and they have these
horns,
you blow bugles and then the,
the elk will go,
what?
You want someone to bitch and I'll come
around the corner for.
Yeah,
looking for another elk to fuck up and
then shoot them.
Would you ever get in like a suit or
anything like that into it and pretend
to be an l,
like sneak up on them.
They have actual,
uh,
elk decoys that they use that they
actually put on the front of the bow.
So like say if you were shooting your
bow right,
you've got your bow here.
Extending in front of your bow is like
a,
an it looks like,
like,
like a female elk.
It's like a deep.
And you're actually shooting through her
at the ELC.
Oh,
it's like a decor that you put on in
front of your boat.
You're drawing back your bow.
We got something here.
It's like a pocket pussy but with a
weapon in it.
Elk Buhner that boy,
what is this?
That is weird.
Popped up when I typed it out.
It's a new product.
What does it say?
Adjustable fit ball cap.
So what is that mask?
It's an l k.
that's a good way to get shot by a dude.
Oh,
it's a good point.
One of those on a one off to.
Oh,
so that's what.
That is what it is.
It's like an elk head,
you know,
has one of those.
John Dudley has something like that.
It's like here's your.
Where's your chicken?
Or tricking him looking girl filter.
That's what you look like.
I don't think their vision is very good.
Oh,
I see.
I think their vision is a.
have you ever watched any of them have
sex or they don't?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I saw one of them.
I saw a male,
a elk fuck a female.
It was crazy.
Really?
Is it pretty cool or is it mashed?
It.
He smashed it so hard.
She went flying forward when she got
tackled and went down to a front knees.
Dan,
he just climbed on top and he's a one
pump chump.
Boom.
He just slammed into it.
Could you tell?
He felt good after it.
He seemed like whatever.
He was screaming when they're fucking
and when they're in heat,
in the breeding,
in the Rut they call it.
It's amazing to watch.
I mean,
this is something they only do once a
year,
so
for 11 months out of the year,
they're cool with each other.
They're all just hanging out together
and one month out of the year to chaos,
just fighting to the death with other
males smashing into it and then every
girl they get a chance,
they bang it out and then when it's over
it's over.
And then this is a cycle of life and
then in the spring the new calves are
born and then they grow up and then a
year later they're hanging around in the
pack and then they get older as they get
older.
The challenge,
the old bowl for dominance and chases
them away and yeah,
it's,
it's a fascinating sort of a ecosystem
when you want.
And then you know,
there's always rules and there's always
bears and there's all these things are
trying to eat them and mountain lions
are killing them.
It's amazing.
That's wild man.
It's neat that you're so in tune with
all of that stuff and that you,
you know,
you're into those worlds.
That sounds like a lot of fun,
you know?
Well,
it's really interesting.
Even if I never ever hunted again,
um,
I would still be fascinated by wildlife.
It is just,
it's one of the more interesting things
about being alive.
There's these other things that are
alive too,
and they're nothing like us.
They are nothing like us.
We're the outliers really.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
But we're the ones who are separated
from them so completely that if we see
one,
it's like a bird sitting on a flag pole
or it's,
you know,
it's fucking coyote and your
neighborhood.
Whoa.
What's he doing here?
You know,
like the,
or a dog,
which is like our friend,
you know,
dot.
I don't even count them as animals.
I know they're animals,
but they're our friends.
It's like when you have dogs,
either they're dependent upon us for
food.
They're part of the family.
It's a totally different deal than like
a pet wolf or a pet bear or some shit.
There's an episode where somebody's dog
plays family feud with them,
know what I'm saying?
So that's A.
Yeah,
you what other animals going to do that?
I saw a dude online who had talked is he
trained his dog to get him a beer and he
put a t.
He tied a towel to the door of the
refrigerator.
You'd say,
go get me a beer,
and the dog would go there.
She would grab a hold of towel,
pull on it.
It would open up the door to the fridge,
should reach in,
grab a can of beer,
run over hand the can of beer to him.
He'd say,
good now.
Go close the door.
And she would go close the door.
She would go grab that towel and use it
to shut that door.
I was like,
that is insane.
That is a super trained animal,
man.
Yeah.
I never had a dog.
I knew we were talking last night at the
company or about your dog and you,
you,
you know,
you guys always seem to be super happy.
Like,
uh,
when y'all go running and everything
we're talking about,
it's cool.
Do you,
uh,
ever have any pets?
No,
I never had any pets.
They were grown up a lot of
responsibility.
They had scary dogs,
like they had loose dogs and our
neighborhoods like rottweilers,
Dobermans,
you know,
so it was like,
it wasn't.
Nobody had a pet like everybody had,
like there were two dogs that were like,
fuck,
you know,
you'd see him fucking and sometimes like
attack.
So it was kind of exciting,
but it wasn't like.
And then a lot of animals got hit by my
house by this highway by trucks and so
we'd go bury the animals sometimes.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So we'd go get the animal,
you know,
pull them right off this little highway
and Barium.
But um,
but yeah,
I never had a pet,
but I would like to have one if I can
get a home one time,
you know,
a home,
a wife and stuff.
And I think I would like to have an
animal.
You know,
they're fun man,
but you gotta really know what you're
getting into.
If you go out of town,
you're going to need somebody to watch
it,
feed it and take care of it,
get that going to make sure you have a
big enough yard where your dog and get
some exercise and they're going to shit
all over the place.
You're going to have to learn how you
pick that up.
You're gonna have to pick that shit up,
you know?
Can you teach them to shit and like a
hole or something?
Nope.
They shit.
Wherever they go outside,
they just find a spot and say this is a
good spot to shit and they just dropped
logs
and then you got logs all over your lawn
and if you go two days without cleaning
those logs and you got eight logs and
pick up and have three dogs show logos
so dogs makes nutro logs,
logs.
You got to go around cleaning it up and
if I don't clean it up,
I'll have that fucking smell going to be
out in the yard.
Like
shit's mouse and you got to get the
scraper,
little scraper and scrape the logs.
And the.
I have a place I'd dump them into.
Yeah,
it's nasty.
Scooping up shit.
Imagine if your grandma just shit all
over your yard.
Just go out.
Go out in the lawn.
Just shits in the yard,
shits on the lawn like grandmas out
there.
Shit.
I got to clean up or shit.
I love her.
But God,
I hate cleaning her shit.
Ya'll would hate cleaning up probably
human shit for some reason.
But I remember them dog shit.
Well,
when I was a kid that had a blend or
neighborhood named Mario,
right?
And He,
uh,
and he was dude,
he ended up dying actually.
He did some pills and drove into an
embankment,
but he,
when I was young he would shit in his
yard,
make me bury it.
And that's how,
that's how I was allowed to be friends
with him.
How did he make you bury it?
He just asked me to do it and I was
afraid not to do it.
I said,
Yo Dude,
you're not going to believe this,
but I took a shit.
And in my yard I can't even bury it
because I'll throw up.
Hey,
do me a favor and go bury it.
Yeah,
he was,
he did.
He was dark man.
He had a,
he had a real dark vision and he would,
uh,
he would,
I mean he probably honestly,
dude,
he probably shit 200,
300 times and I buried it.
I swear to God on,
I swear to God,
I swear to God dude.
And He um,
had to not run out of places to make new
holes.
Did you think you ever dug up old shit
to put in new shit?
Oh yeah.
I wouldn't be surprised man.
We basically had like the only setup,
I had not even have a strong system.
The only setup,
I was like one of those plastic.
A beach.
Oh no setup.
I was seven.
So wait a minute.
This seven year old was doing this.
How old was he?
He was eight or nine.
Oh,
he's tricking you buy an older.
He was older and two years when you're
seven is a long stretch now when you 32,
30 2:34,
that don't mean shit.
Whatever.
Dude.
Seven and nine.
That's a big stretch.
Yeah.
You go shit.
At your house,
Buddy.
That's what I tell people now.
For too long he would.
What was the,
do you remember the first?
There's no way.
You really remember.
I remember what,
I don't remember what he said,
but I remember.
How did it happen?
How did it happen when you find yourself
with a plastic shovel and another
person?
Shit going down.
How did it come to this?
Well,
it came to it because he,
I know my brother probably wasn't around
and I wanted somebody to play with and
he was older so I was hanging out and he
was deviant man.
How?
So?
He just had a little bit of like,
um,
like he was kind of slithering,
you know what I'm talking about from
mom.
He knew how to manipulate you.
Yeah.
He was obviously burgers.
Shit.
200 plus times.
Like there wasn't here.
The same color on the outside of design.
The inside of his.
It took them about demon.
Yeah,
like a light day.
Diablo?
Yeah,
like an ld below.
But also who was an elementary school.
Interesting.
Um,
but he,
uh,
so when you first found yourself,
do you remember the feeling that you
first found when you were digging a hole
for a dude?
Shit.
Like,
just thinking,
what am I?
How long can I do this?
What if he keeps asking,
how do I stop this?
How did you wind up stopping?
That's maybe a better question.
You know what?
I don't remember how it kind of,
you know,
pat,
you know how he turned off?
Yeah,
petered off.
I don't remember how it kind of tapered
off to his parents ever.
Like,
Hey,
do you ever shit in the house?
How come we don't have any missing
toilet paper?
Well,
did you know that's what I think it was.
I think he was lazy.
He was serious and he shut outside
behind his slide.
They had a slide in his yard because
they had,
you know,
a little bit of money and he shot
outside behind the slot is a great word
too,
by the way.
And it was silty kind of soil and sand.
And I remember going over then I still
remember,
I don't remember the shade of it
honestly.
Would it look like,
I would say like a tope,
but a little with a little more brown
and you can always find coyote shit
because it has like little berries in
it.
A lot of times coyotes eat all kinds of
things.
Yeah.
Eat some berries.
Sometimes I'll see these logs,
like these little red berries in and I'm
like,
Oh God,
Shit.
It's always a dark brown to their shit's
super consistent.
It's weird.
Goose has have fancy shit sometimes I
see him.
You mean disgusting?
Yeah.
I never liked it,
but it seems creatures.
Yeah,
and that's a bait and switch by mother
nature because if you see a goose you
think,
oh,
this is fun,
this can be exciting,
and then they'll fucking choke out an
infant at a park.
I mean gooses are violent.
They're violent,
extremely violent,
and they,
they,
they fight impacts,
impacts where they do.
I have a friend who had a house on a
lake and they had a wire all around the
lake.
I was like,
what's the wire for delegates to keep
the goose from going into the water?
They don't want them to waddle and into
the water of the things.
I was like,
is that electric?
Like what kind of fence is that?
I'm not sure if they.
I'm not sure if it's electric.
It might give them a little shock,
but the idea was to try to keep the.
Because they shit all over their lawn.
The shit all over near where the.
They had a pond in their yard.
They're looks like the ultimate,
like the Kid Marissa,
just like that kid Mario.
But a bird.
Bollinger you and have a pond in your
yard.
Like you want to go fishing?
Yeah,
let's take five steps out of my
backyard.
You know?
I mean that is like the ultimate,
but I don't think that's it.
I don't think if you have a natural hill
in new yard kind of.
I don't think that's that expensive to
get water would it?
And to get a pump put in.
I don't think it's that drastic man.
I would think that'd be a nightmare,
but they're going to make sure it
doesn't leak like you had.
I'm like,
what's going to keep the water there?
It takes a special kind of bottom,
like when you go to a natural lake,
like that's the water is pulled up there
for a reason.
Like that's an unusual ground.
You got to realize if you're looking at
a natural leg,
unless it's a glacial lake,
waters decide to stay there.
Whereas the same amount of water's
probably landed everywhere,
but it's decided to stay there.
So what the hell is different between
that ground and all the other ground
around it.
So when you want to make a pond,
you just can't make a pond everywhere.
There's a reason why there's not a pond
there because that's not the kind of
ground for a pond.
So they would have to put a liner in.
Ah,
you got to teen mother.
It's like taming mother nature almost.
You have to do something.
You can't just pour water in there and
you've got to do something.
And one of the things that they do in a
lot of places,
they use this really thick Koi pond
liner.
It's basically a plastic liner.
So you got a bullshit ass fake pond is
what you got that's going to look
shitty.
Go above ground pool.
Yeah.
No,
basically the above ground pool of
ponds.
It's not even organized,
you know?
Well,
once they get the liner in place,
then they put surface levels of dirt and
rocks and stuff over the line or.
So it looks like a regular pond,
but the thing is what's holding the
water in place in some places they,
they'll use those Koi pond you ever
seen?
You know what a coin.
It's big.
Beautiful.
At a restaurant.
Yeah.
They have very thick liner that they
used for the base of that Shit.
Used that stuff on float tanks to
flotation tanks.
We floated them.
Uh Nah.
I mean I've heard you talk about it
before.
The liner of those things is the same
thing.
It's Koi pond,
like a liner.
It's like a real thick,
durable,
tough plastic.
Does it feel like you're alive when
you're in the tank?
Yeah.
It feels like you're relaxing.
You know,
it's a good feeling.
It feels good on your body.
It just alleviates tension,
but it also feels like you're in this
meditative state.
You relax and you think about things
better.
There you get a good,
good thought of,
you know,
what,
how you,
how to look at things from an outside
looking in perspective.
Yeah.
You get a chance to be away from your
body really because you're not thinking
about your body just floating.
Oh,
I like that.
You're not feeling your body at all.
The water is the same temperature as
your skin,
so you don't.
You can't even tell where the water is
and where the,
where your body is.
So I like that.
Yeah.
I just feel like you're flying through
the air and it's all dark and you don't
see anything.
You don't hear anything because your
ears are underwater.
Does it feel dead?
Do you feel like might be dead or not?
No,
definitely not.
I like that he worried about the feeling
of dead.
I'm just worried about how does the
fizz.
Any like does your brain keep going,
you know,
or whatever it is.
That keeps us going in our.
Like when you die,
he like,
does our consciousness,
does it just leave out of this shell and
then we're just part of this straight up
fucking.
I think part of the thing is when we're
thinking about consciousness,
we're thinking about language,
so we're thinking about the way we talk
and think about a feeling.
Yeah,
because I think what we think of as
consciousness,
when I think of it,
when my own limited mind,
when I think of consciousness,
I think of consciousness as me using
language to interpret how I feel about
different things.
I have this a language touch to it.
I think if something happens when you
die in your soul goes to another place.
Let's say a soul as a real thing or
consciousness,
a real thing.
I bet it goes there with no language and
I bet that's real similar.
I bet to what it feels like when you're
really tripping,
when you're on some heavy psychedelics
and you just melt into the universe and
you.
You sort of ceased to exist on some of
them,
like five Meo dmt been,
yeah,
melt into the center of the universe.
You feel like you don't exist anymore.
I bet death and that feels like you're
dying to.
That's.
That's a scary one.
Five.
MEO DMT is a universally disturbing one.
Lot of people have problem with that one
because it really does feel like you're
dying.
Can senior citizens do it or not?
I think they can.
Yeah.
I think the.
The only problem would be if you had a
heart attack freaked out.
I'm think it's toxic because your body
makes it.
Your body knows what to do with it too.
You know your body knows how to bring
you back down to sobriety levels in like
15,
20 minutes.
Do you know when you're going into those
kinds of,
when you're ill and some of that,
do you get a feeling that if you're a
good or bad person,
did you get.
Do you get like an ant that like I'm
trying to get a feeling if there's
things that are bothering you about your
behavior.
You know,
if you're a.
If you have something that's that's
haunting you and maybe with a lot of
people it really comes down to life
choices,
not just in terms of like their
behavior,
but even like what they're doing with
for living and how they're living their
life and sometimes those experiences.
The psychedelic experiences can
highlight these things that are
bothering you,
but that you're suppressing and then you
realize like,
oh,
this a suppressing of these feelings and
thoughts is actually making me lash out
in these other ways and I've got shitty
behavior and aggressive in this way and
it's really because of this lab.
It's really because of.
And then you might,
you know,
might also come to realization.
It's about something that happened when
you were a child.
It's about feeling unprotected or
unloved as a child and it's just,
you never developed properly,
so you never felt totally secure.
So you want to do something to make you
feel secure,
whether it's drinking or something.
And then you'll see that in a
psychedelic experience,
you'd be able to like see the root of it
better.
Oh Wow.
For a lot of people its cessation of um,
uh,
of smoking comes from that feeling like,
oh,
this is killing myself because I hate
myself.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I'm literally poisoning myself.
Like how could I not see this?
And then through having a mushroom
experience,
they've just completely quit.
Really.
So yeah,
it's a real common one,
real common ones.
There's a lot of other stuff that I
haven't done that also like Ibogaine is
a big one for getting people off drugs.
That's a huge one.
I heard about that.
That's a big one that has an amazing
success rate,
but it's supposed to be really brutal.
And as far as like how you feel like
look it,
it runs you through the ringer
psychologically,
but when you get through it it's worth
it.
But it's 24 hours.
Fuck.
And who do you have to go with by
yourself?
So there's a lot of clinics that do it,
particularly in Mexico.
A lot of people go down to Mexico and go
to these clinics and their 24 hour
clinics of this Ibogaine experience.
Jre field trip.
But Hey man,
if you had a son and if you like Joe,
my son is hooked on oxygen,
I don't know what to do.
I would 100 percent recommend you do
that.
Really?
Yeah.
Because I know so many people that have
done it and it's helped them and it
rewires the way your brain connects to
addiction.
It's really fast.
It's a fascinating drug.
Hamilton Morris,
who is the host of vices,
Hamilton's Pharmacopia.
It's a essentially a show that's all
just about drugs.
He was talking about it last week about
how fascinating it is and in low doses
that actually is like a nootropic.
It actually enhances your consciousness
and low doses makes you smarter.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
you know,
uh,
I want to get into some of that kind of
stuff,
but I mean,
I,
you know,
so right now I don't party or anything
like that,
so I struggle with that.
It's like,
man,
you know,
because I don't,
it's tough because I do want to be able
to be,
do things that are beneficial for myself
and things that I didn't have a problem
with,
but it's hard just hard to kind of
balance.
Yeah.
You want to stay sober.
Well,
you know,
sobriety is a worthwhile goal and if you
can go from being a person who's doing a
lot of drugs and ruining their life,
the person who is like yourself that's
on a great path and you're sober and
you're disciplined,
you wouldn't want to break that.
You don't want to have that bad feeling.
Um,
but there's ways that you can achieve
certain psychedelic states,
uh,
without any drugs.
One of the big ones is yoga and
meditation.
Those are two big ones.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't do the kind of yoga that gives
you a psychedelic experience.
I think mostly that's Kundalini Yoga,
but the kind of yoga that I do,
um,
that beaker from hot yoga shit,
it's just this,
this what it does to your body and
chills you out afterwards.
I think it has a pretty profound effect
on the way the world,
the way you experience the world after
the classes.
So I think that's something that people
don't take into consideration.
Like one way in which you can change the
world around you is to change how you
interface with the world and how you
experience the world.
How are you viewing it?
What is your,
what's your behavior of a flavored by?
Is your behavior motivated by
frustration and weirdness and insecurity
and anger or is your behavior motivated
by love and confidence and happiness and
are you like,
are you quenched physically?
Do you feel good physically and if you
do and if you've experienced like a
strong yoga class and then you run into
someone,
you might be more relaxed,
more compassionate,
more easily,
and that that'll change the way that
person thinks about you.
That'll change your interaction with
them in the future.
That might change your whole life and if
you continue to act that way and you
continue to look at the world through
the eyes of this very particular
discipline,
it's really good for your body.
It really can change.
People change a lot of people.
It's like there's a definite butterfly
effect from that.
Yeah,
so if you want to just do something for
you,
I'm just meditate.
Men Learn how to meditate.
Yeah.
I just got a new meditation chair
actually yesterday,
so I might have to start getting maybe
getting into it too.
Why not,
man?
I mean,
if you were interested in doing drugs
right,
why not just be interested in doing
something that you know you can
definitely do and it's not going to fuck
you up and it's only gonna help you
when you were,
um,
when you were partying,
what was your thing?
Just doing cocaine by myself at the
house.
Really?
Cocaine.
It was all cocaine.
Yeah.
What about Bu's?
The Bu's bother,
you know,
I just couldn't have a drink because I'd
be afraid that I would buy.
I would buy a coke.
So if you got drunk then it would loosen
your inhibitions and you'd be like,
where's the coke with the fucking coke?
Yeah,
dude and cocaine.
Oh,
go back to that vest or a man.
So here's what happened.
So I,
you know,
I would get,
I would do some cocaine at thousand,
put on these different vests.
I many.
Did you buy it again?
I don't know.
I spent too much on them,
but I would probably say
the priciest one I had was probably
about $210.
Nine.
Damn.
Yeah.
And so I would get fucked up and put
these vests on.
And put on sunglasses and not know like
Buffalo Bill Shit,
but at least party and by myself,
you know,
and one time I was making a smoothie,
because I,
you know,
I have,
I got like a new unknown what kind of
blender it is,
but it's pretty nice and I was making
like a nice smoothie and I'm fucking
coked up on party and you know,
living high on the hog to vests on
maybe.
Right.
And I thought,
I thought I heard something outside.
Right.
Which is kind of weird to even think of
when you have a blender going.
Right?
So I'll leave out of my apartment to go
in the hallway,
lock myself out with the blender going
in the morning,
coked up out of my brain.
Now I have to go to my landlord dude who
lives right down the hall and tell him
like,
hey man,
I got logged out.
Blenders on.
Oh my God,
he must have hated you.
Owe the blender shorts out and smoke
happens.
The fire alarm starts going off in the
building,
right as I'm at his door knocking right
now.
He's pissed and he's like,
what's going on?
And I didn't know what to say.
I told him that I was throwing a late
Christmas party.
Dude,
it was fucking into January.
I will with you
at the time,
Huh?
Oh,
this is two and half years ago.
So he comes back to my apartment.
Right?
He's locks the door.
There's nobody in there.
Oh my God
man.
But that's it.
It was fun.
Oh my God.
No,
that was fun.
How long have you lived there for?
I still live there.
Yeah,
passionate.
You know,
like I've caught him doing some things.
I think we're all even.
How long have you been
sober for a two year.
In two weeks.
It'll be two years.
What was the big thing where you like,
oh,
I gotta get my shit together.
Your Dad was going on.
Opie and Jim when Jim Norton had a radio
show,
it's serious and it was actually on a,
it's on [inaudible] that show that he
had.
This is not happening.
Um,
and I ended up,
uh,
doing coke all night driving a taxi.
I was in a taxi driver.
This dude,
Luigi
got me an escort,
I didn't want to escort.
We're doing cocaine and like Harlem or
something North Harlem and the cab
driver doing coke and I just had,
I was taking a cab from a party to my
hotel and so we end up off on this other
excursion.
Next thing you know,
I'm driving the taxi,
he's in the back with the hooker.
It's 5:30 in the morning and I got to be
on the radio station at 6:30 or
something.
So I get to the radio and I can't even
talk.
And uh,
and darryl strawberry's the other guest,
right?
Who the baseball player who also had
drug problem,
but he's like 13 years sober.
And so it was this weird moment where
like,
I thought I was kind of cool,
but then here's a man who like,
I'd always in my head maybe somewhere
thought,
oh,
that caused like a cokehead within here
he is eloquent,
put together successful.
And here I am,
I can't even talk.
And I'm with two men that I admire.
Um,
you know,
opie and Jim Norton.
Just to be honored and to be on the
show,
you know,
and so I was like,
this is,
I'm,
I'm not making choices.
Like there's some,
there's some unevenness here,
you know.
So what did you do after the 2012 step
programs?
One 12 step program.
Yeah.
And then so yeah.
So I've been in that.
Then since then it,
it's helped me out,
you know?
Well,
I would definitely say don't do coke.
Yeah.
The problem with drugs is they're all
under the same blanket.
Right.
You know when someone says drugs,
you think of everything,
you think of pills,
you think of smoking it,
you think of coke,
you think a pot,
you think of mushrooms.
Think of everything.
Yeah.
But obviously they're not all the same
thing.
You know?
It's weird to call them all drugs.
Yeah.
They affect you very differently.
One hundred percent.
I don't think if you did mushrooms you
would all of a sudden be doing blow and
know.
Yeah.
I don't think so either from Luigi cab
again.
Right?
I don't think so either so,
but I think I wouldn't want to be the
guy that told you to do now I don't feel
like you are,
but,
you know,
I feel like it's something that I think
about sometimes and um,
but uh,
you know,
I don't know because I also do want to
have experiences where like I'm able to
get,
you know,
unique experiences out of my car,
out of my mind and think about other
stuff and like,
you know,
I do remember times where mushrooms
would just clear my conscience.
They would be like,
someone came up to the chalkboard where
everybody written all these math
problems and bullshit and somebody's
drawn a dick and uh,
somebody fucking cutting off somebodies
head,
just stupid shit and just cleaned it all
off.
And you're like,
ugh.
No,
I think so too.
It was relaxing mushrooms,
forgive you.
We give you free your mistakes.
I mean,
this is one of the reasons why I'm like,
mushrooms and Jesus are always kind of
connected in folklore and a lot of
people's ideas because they're both very
forgiving.
Like,
here's the best Jesus store.
If someone being forgiving,
God damn coughing while it's the weed.
Um,
there was a guy named general butt
naked.
You ever heard of that guy?
Real man?
Yeah.
He lived in Liberia and he's a famous
character in Liberia because of his
exploits.
When he was in the middle of war,
he would,
uh,
he would go and fight naked.
Oh Wow.
And he was a cannibal.
He would kill innocent children on the
other side in eat pieces of their heart.
And he believed that it would protect
them in battle and talks about it
openly.
After doing this,
he found Jesus and he came over here.
He is this him?
Did you have actual photos?
Photos of him?
I didn't know either.
So then he became he,
I mean,
he's killed thousands of people.
Oh,
he's apparently in,
in war.
And then according to what he said,
and then afterwards became a preacher
and talks openly about the fact that
he's killed innocent children and eating
pieces of their heart.
But people forgive him because he's a
preacher.
So his love of Jesus is so complete that
people forgive him to the point where
they're.
Forgive the fact that he ate kids.
Wow.
Imagine how powerful he was.
If he was your.
It was your kid that this guy eight.
Then you see him out preaching.
Now I'd be pissed off Bro.
You Ain't my kid.
Yeah,
it is hard the fuck.
But there was a different time.
Yeah,
that was a different man.
it's crazy.
The,
the,
the.
For travelers guy.
I forget what it's called,
the vice travel guide to Liberia.
It is a really,
really eye opening.
I'm sort of a view into what Liberia is
like.
Light.
Liberia is a really,
really poor,
dangerous part of Africa.
That was originally when slaves
left America,
when they were set free,
they went back to Liberia and that's
where they settled.
Fuck yeah.
Dude,
I Africa's always fucked up,
huh?
Yeah.
That sucks man.
That's why I'm all these wild animals
stories from Africa.
And so this is another one that was kind
of interesting.
These poachers got eaten by a lion.
They,
uh,
tried to get ahold of a rhino.
They were trying to steal,
kill this rhino and cut it.
Turns off they try to sell them and they
just get eaten.
That's crazy.
Did too.
That's the way to go.
If you could get an animal Oregon put
into your body,
would you do it
will be the benefit.
Would you get I do something.
Would you get like a Hyena?
But when I'm shiny,
but I already have the blood of a down
syndrome boy.
I said I don't know what I would get
mad.
I would probably get just something.
I'd start off with something small,
probably like,
you know,
a wrist or something or like a pinky
nail.
The Leopard Xal gravy that
once they said splicing genes,
man,
Dan wants you to be able to do with
people.
You're going to be like,
that guy ty grid.
What's that guy on a condo?
ACAT member.
You're going to be like,
thundercat.
Who's what?
I don't remember that guy with the red
man.
He was like,
never tried that.
I know it's definitely illegal,
but do you think there's a scientists
tried.
I met a guy twice in people with
animals.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it wasn't that something that they were
trying.
Stalin was trying to do that with
chimpanzees.
Yeah.
He was trying to make some sort of a
chimp human hybrid.
Yeah,
I could see it,
man.
I've met some motherfuckers.
Did some motherfucker.
Yeah.
Well I think they're going to be able to
do something like that soon.
Dave,
can you afford that?
You fucking are talking to somebody and
then they just get into a bird bath.
Can you fucking imagine that?
This is that humanity thing.
Scientists claim US lab engineered to
Mansi human chimp hybrid.
One hundred years ago.
Scientist.
This is a really recent article.
Huh?
This isn't science alert though.
Oh,
this is the sun.
Super Sketchy,
right?
Yeah.
That humanity was real weird though.
The thing walked up right?
A lot.
Yeah,
and they wore a suit.
What is that?
That's,
that's Stalin's humanz experience,
but that one picture is real.
That one,
that one,
the one next to the one year at that
one.
That's real.
That's what it really looked like
thing.
Walked around with shorts on.
Yeah.
Luda side of his quads on that
motherfucker will tear you apart.
Yeah.
The thing I think it got very close to
the woman to which became an issue.
Look at data.
Who is that?
That's the humanity.
I put tie
Dean Martin's friend.
Steve Martin's buddy.
Yeah.
Look,
he's dealing coke with.
What's his effort is that they got from
Norco to sit in the background,
but stop looking at that language.
That's what I'm talking about.
Look at the writing.
Tell me that shit doesn't look alien.
Like that's from some spaceship.
Like what language is that?
I don't know.
I'm.
I'm ready for it all man.
Language was a Japanese.
Yeah.
That looks like it should be on.
Yeah,
don't,
don't go back.
Translate it.
There we go.
The language looks.
It does look like.
Like it's from space.
Like if you saw that on.
He didn't know anything about Asian
languages.
Do you saw that on a spaceship?
He'd be like,
Oh,
do you think Japanese people could be
from space and not know that they are
the people that are really into
nonsense.
I'm like the Zacharias situation.
Do you know about all that shit?
There's people that believe that there
is a planet that's out far outside of
Pluto that comes.
It's an on an elliptical orbit and it
comes near Earth every like 3000 years
or something.
I forget the exact number,
but it's called Nibiru and on the bureau
there are these people called the
[inaudible] and what they are is an
alien race and that this alien race
engineered us and they took,
they took these old monkeys like a
ancient hominids and then they added
their DNA to him and created a human
being.
This is the idea.
And then the guys,
Zechariah wrote all these books on this
stuff and there's a lot of people that
think he's full of shit,
but it's interesting.
It's fun.
It's fun to.
It's fun to speculate,
you know,
but the idea was that different groups
of people got different level of alien.
Hm.
Yeah.
I could get will.
Look,
sometimes I'm talking to somebody,
I'm like,
I don't think this dude's like a full
person.
You know,
like,
who,
who do we know?
Don't tell mom.
I don't know if it's anybody that we
know.
I mean,
Josh Martin,
that works.
Sometimes it takes me for a ride,
but I don't know it be an alien.
Imagine if there was one just living
amongst us.
Oh,
the whole time.
We're just getting our chain yanked.
Oh,
I bet.
I'm sure there's some chick out there
that's fucked an alien.
I think when I really think about it,
I think that that would be the first
inbreeding would be a chick would let an
alien fucker.
Oh,
it would be a dude who fucked an alien
girl.
Oh No.
I think now these days there's a.
I could see some women fucking some
aliens.
Boy,
isn't that some of the folk lore though,
some of the stories of male alien
abduction or like female aliens that
seduce them.
Yeah.
That's how they get your loads,
bro.
Dude.
Species.
I've been given a free sign.
Natasha Hendrick,
right?
Is that her last name?
Hendrix.
How do you say it?
And stritch.
Hence trich.
So they said,
how many loads can your body make you?
She was on fear factor.
She's very nice.
She's a very nice person.
So really you met her?
Yeah,
she did.
An episode of fear factor.
Hottest.
Wow.
Forest Whitaker was in that movie.
Oh,
I love forrest whitaker.
Damn ghost dog.
I'll listen in the hustler.
And he's in no last king of Scotland.
He was in the color of money,
not the hustler.
You know what movie I like is um,
that movie where they escaped from the
mental health facility and Michael
Keaton's in it and it's like four dudes
and they go to a baseball game.
You remember that movie?
No,
I think it makes me think you probably
wouldn't be able to make that movie
today.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Because a mental health facility or some
people will be upset.
Well,
there's always dudes in movies would
play those guys that would play someone
smart who is mentally challenged.
Oh yeah.
Like that's a common thing dudes would
always do that.
Didn't Sean Penn play?
Someone challenged?
Yeah.
Great movie with Dustin Hoffman.
Did he do it?
Oh,
that's all right.
Wayne man.
Rosie O'donnell,
who?
Dustin Hoffman was probably the first
guy to play a super autistic man.
And he did great.
Rosie O'donnell did it too,
right?
I think so,
man.
That's the last thing you want your
enemies finding out
there to imagine the outtake.
Three days didn't really get my start
laughing.
Imagine the outtakes.
If you start laughing,
you monster and nowadays you have to
have a real person with the disease on
the side of the stage.
So like the consult.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that real?
Yeah,
that's crazy,
man.
Come on.
Really?
I'm sure you think they're letting you
do that without having somebody there to
verify if it's legit or not.
Well,
how would someone verify whether or not
like,
like if someone's going to come up and
go,
that's not how I do it.
I just thought this is not your thing.
Who is this?
Rosie?
That's Rosie.
Let me hear this
ahead.
I like,
I like Blue Card or green card.
Oh,
that's true.
I just made that up.
A bus driver.
You,
Amanda?
Amanda Funeral.
Have you been waiting two hours.
Why didn't you wait inside or riding the
bus with my sister condensate and May I
have your address?
Honestly.
Bath,
you know,
you just make things harder on yourself.
Buckle up for safety.
Whoa,
pretty good.
I'm wondering if you could do that movie
today,
you might not be able to do it like 12
years ago.
I guess that's a different world,
man.
It definitely was a different world,
You can't even barely breathe out there.
They know it's tough.
Right.
But dude,
I can't believe I'm going to China and
they're wondering,
you can do anything.
Can you do anything?
As far as like comedy material trouble.
I mean I just think of all the different
stuff they have.
The animals are treated differently
there.
Oh,
that's true.
You know?
Right.
But I think you get in trouble if you
google certain websites,
like they have a different version of
their.
They're censored.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna do anything drastic like
that.
Be Crazy.
You get sensor a billion people.
How the hell did you do that?
That's pretty impressive,
dude.
I remember going when I was a student,
we went to Cuba when I was a student in
college right now.
I remember we went to a bookstore and
all the books just started at like a
certain year and that was it.
Like there was no.
Imagine that,
and it was like in the 19 whatever,
when Castro took over [inaudible].
This is going on today in China,
World Cup,
kiss,
spark,
social media,
debate on sexual harassment in China.
Why a male reporter in these two Russian
fans gave him a kiss while he was
recuperating and it's caused like a
reverse sexual harassment debate and
transparent.
It's a big deal.
Wow.
He looks so.
What's a big deal that in China,
someone like you're not allowed to show
public affection like that.
Is that what the big debate is?
Here's the.
It came after a bunch of female
journalists have been assaulted and so
they started assaulting the dude the
other way around.
I'm going to go out on a limb.
He's going to be okay.
He looks fine.
He looks actually better than kissed on
the cheek by attractive women.
They're not hurting them.
They can't rape him.
I think he's going to be okay.
Let's watch on boy,
get mauled by these hot Russian broads
here.
Coast wow.
Kiss.
Nope,
nothing,
nothing.
He's fine.
He's laughing.
Okay,
we're done.
He's laughing.
We're done.
Stop this.
People are fucking crazy.
The guys laughing,
he thought it was cute.
Yeah.
Why would anybody make a deal out of
that?
It's a zero tolerance.
That girl literally had a plastic Red
Cup in her hand,
which is the universal sign for being
fucked up in public.
Have you got that Plastic Red Cup in
your hand?
That chick's probably lit.
She kissed that guy.
Yeah.
He thought it was cute.
They didn't move them around or push
them or assault him.
It was a friendly gesture on the cheek.
This love.
I think while we trying to shut down
people enjoying each other,
I don't think we are anymore.
I think.
I think things are actually,
think things are getting in a lot better
place in it.
Just on in the media.
It seems like they're not.
Sometimes you know well that,
that that seemed like the not the fact
that someone's making a big deal out of
that.
That's true.
You can't look.
You can't compare that to a bunch of
guys doing that to a girl.
It's not the same.
It's not devastating.
The guy's going to be fine.
It is different.
Men and women are different.
In that case,
that is a very clear cut case of no one
got hurt there.
Did they interrupt his broadcast?
Perhaps?
Did they ruin what he was trying to say
and I don't know what.
He might have had a serious message and
these taught Russian broads come over
and kiss him on the cheek.
Maybe they fucked up his little project
and what he's trying to accomplish,
but there's no crime there.
That's not a crime.
It's not the same.
If there was a bunch of dudes doing that
to a pretty girl,
some gorilla looking fucking football
player,
fucking corn fed.
Iowa boys came over and kissed her and
be like,
Ooh,
what are they doing?
You remember when they were trying to
make it a big deal because Katy Perry
kiss some guy on American idol.
Yes.
Remember,
this is like two months ago,
she kissed him.
Boy never kissed a boy.
She kissed him.
She brought him over and kissed him,
and there was like,
oh,
well what if worth Katy Perry was a man
that was a girl.
She's
stop.
She's Katy Perry,
and if that guy is really complained
that Carrie,
Katy Perry took her kiss my tears for
me.
Dude.
No one's going to love you.
Shut the fuck up.
If you can't appreciate Katy Perry
kissing you.
Oh,
she's pretty.
She was pretty and more people will love
that man because Katy Perry kissed him.
Idol contestant shuts down Katy Perry.
He shut down the Katy Perry backlash.
He kissed her to listen.
Nothing wrong with that.
Looking at,
first of all,
homeys k right Izzy,
look at him.
He could be from Idaho pushing him and
he fell down.
That is not a male movie.
That's not.
Oh,
he could be.
Okay.
It might be that he's avoiding a that
kiss until he really did find the woman
that made him feel like you wanted to be
kissed and maybe she stole that from
them.
Yeah.
See,
right there.
Right here.
Imagine if a 33 year old male artists
tricked and 19 year old female or do a
kids like Katy Perry.
Well,
imagine that's a different thing you
fuck about you.
Imagine that's a whole different thing.
I don't pretend to men and women are the
same.
You fucking assholes.
Imagine a Volkswagen.
Fuck your stepmom.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh Dad,
what are we doing?
This stupid thing,
man.
It's just not the same thing.
Everybody's okay.
That Chinese guy was laughing,
man.
Oh,
he probably jerked off to the video at
the house multiple times.
Did I am going to fucking China to ask
them?
Somebody told me a different fruit over
there.
Can you could imagine that?
Sure.
They have different fruit in Brazil.
They have different fruit in England.
You get some different fruit.
Fuck man.
I'm excited.
I guess I'm nervous,
but I'm also excited.
How many shows are you doing over there?
I'm doing three shows,
but you know,
uh,
and I've,
you know,
I don't know about the.
Promote a guy hit me up literally over
email and like,
oh wow,
I'm going.
But next thing you know,
you've got a ball.
Gag mouth tied up in a basement,
under a noodle shop somewhere.
As long as I get to eat after Jesus
Christ.
Are you looking forward to the food?
No,
man,
no.
Do you?
Not like Chinese food,
I mean not like it,
but somebody told me that you can eat
animal dicks over there.
You can eat fucking elbow.
You were saying that you need human
dirks.
I think you were just joking around
though,
right?
I don't know honestly.
Think about it.
Think what else.
You went over there and they said,
we heard you on Joe Rogan experience and
we have a hockey rink and we're prepared
to put on the lion fight.
Are you prepared to watch?
Would if they brought to you to a place
and I said,
Dude's gonna.
Fight a line with a sword.
You could leave if you like.
Yeah.
Would you stay?
I would say yeah,
you'd have to.
I would owe it to them.
If the man's already gonna fight and I'm
the only.
Well imagine he comes out to fight a
minute.
Nobody's hitting the fucking stadium.
Well,
you would have to be able to trust the
people that are there that they're going
to let this guy get ripped apart by line
in front of you and then they get rid of
a body.
Yeah.
Would you eat during it or would you
wait to eat after?
Gosh,
it depends on how hungry I was thinking.
Wait.
Yeah.
If they got looks over and you're
fucking eating,
holly's fighting for eating a hot dog.
What?
This guy's getting mauled and he looks
up at you.
Makes eye contact like
you were just saying,
muster on your face and shit.
Like what is it?
Sour Kraut and your teeth
drinking a beer fall.
Fuck his head.
Oh Jesus.
Bartender do that.
When you think about that movie
gladiator with Russell Crowe.
What is that supposed to be?
How long ago was that?
Was it supposedly based?
That was like a thousand years ago or
more.
I think it was like 980.
I'm guessing more to let's go.
2,000 [inaudible].
That ain't shit dude.
That ain't that long.
Says it's set in Roman times.
So could we get back there you think was
exactly.
Yeah.
Thanks man.
Says that's not that long ago.
The people were fucking 8,100.
One 81 88.
I was in Rome a couple of years back and
I went to the coliseum.
It's fucking amazing,
man.
It's crazy to be there just to feel it
and then most of it's missing like they
stripped down a lot of the stone people
stole things from it and it's like it's
all dilapidated and falling apart,
but they go on a tour,
Louis,
they take you through the catacombs and
they sort of explained all the different
things,
but they had these animals they'd gotten
from Africa and they had kept them in
the see that hole in the ground.
That's really real.
That's really how they did it,
man.
These animals would come out out of a
fucking hole in the ground and you see
that first layer of people,
the first seat,
the first row seats,
they had to put up fucking fences.
It's shit because the Tigers would leap
through the hair and kill the people
that were in the first row.
Stub hub
people up those stubhub,
those season pass holders.
Imagine you get that Nice ticket and you
fucked your buddy.
You Get up to get a soda and you come
back and your buddies just in pieces do
that.
Just the fact that people did do stuff
like that.
We did that.
It's in us.
Do you know that?
That's what's crazy,
man.
That's what your show makes me think
about.
Stuff like that.
Like that.
There's DNA inside of us that remembers
that.
Well,
I think when people get into situations
where they need entertainment and back
then right,
like would you rather go to a play or
see a dude have a sword fight against
the tiger.
Tiger?
Yeah.
All Day.
Depends on what plays are.
Boring couple plays will be good.
I mean what,
what?
Playing Neverland.
Maybe if you.
I mean if there's a line and on the left
you get to see a guy fight align with a
sword and on the right you see a bunch
of people pretend to be cast.
That's going to say a lot about humanity
salesman or whatever the fuck you going
to watch,
bitch,
I'm going to go see that guy get eaten.
You gotta watch it.
It's terrifying to watch.
But the,
the shock and the,
the just the entertainment value before
death of
the fights we.
Yeah,
we got tickets to be the worst.
The good stories have been written yet,
so what the hell do you think they were
doing?
They had plays,
they had great stories and I'm sure they
had great stories but just not as good
like and also the value of human life
was so much lower than people were
constantly going to war and the war that
they fought,
they fought with bows and arrows and
spears and swords.
So there's just bloodiness horrible
bloodiness.
There's probably four or five dead
people on the street at the moment.
So you.
So maybe you're like,
am I going to go see somebody else die
in there and we see this play and part
of the problem was the way they got rid
of this shit too,
right?
Like the streets would be contaminated
with shit should have buried it like we
did around my neighborhood.
Imagine the blow back.
If someone in some country did put
together a coliseum and then people
started traveling there and it became
like the new hot spot.
Well if I lived in Africa I would do
that because it's,
you know,
I know that some places are so starved.
They have so many animals.
I think they have a lot of people
believe in reincarnation.
Well,
we'll just do it a million dollars to
have a sword fight.
If you had a purse of a million dollars
for someone,
have a sword fight in the.
Give him a shield and armor and a sword
and a helmet.
They're going to have a sword fight with
a tiger.
People would sign up for that.
I mean,
I feel like if you had known was better
than anybody because you guys spend,
you spend more time around,
you know,
the closest kind of thing.
Maybe we have some type of gladiators.
Modern Day.
What do you think?
Would any of those men do it?
Yeah.
People would do it.
What does this Jamie in 2011 man fights
lion to boost Egypt.
Tourism.
What?
Come on.
This is real.
Sitting in there with a little plastic
lawn chair.
It's got a shield.
It's got a spear and shield as shady as
fuck.
What the fuck,
dude?
Hell yeah.
A lot of room.
Either.
Not a giant line.
Is this?
This actually happened.
It says 100 percent live like recorded
videos on CBS news.
Jesus Christ.
This guy get jacked or what isn't.
That's not showing it.
It must have been a long fight and it
was probably subdued.
Oh,
be a tap.
It's obviously happening.
If this guy recorded,
then it's probably happened.
He had to do like a two minutes or
something with it a bit.
Yeah,
the line seems fine.
He's going to climb on top.
He's a wrestler.
Yeah.
He's going to do like a fucking cage
drop.
Drop down on that line.
You imagine that the ball's.
You'd have to leap down with a spear and
drive it through the lions brain
from the top rope
play.
Spray all over the place.
You could do it.
Someone would do it.
If that dummy got in there with that
lion you.
He could definitely get.
If you gave someone a million dollars,
he gave them a shield and a sword in
armor.
Given some armor.
Not all armor.
You can pick the neck of the loin piece
at lion would leap on you so fast.
You're sore to be knocked out of your
hand.
It would just crush your fucking head
with its teeth.
Well,
one man would do it.
Yeah.
One man would win
maybe the mountain from game of thrones.
The giant dude.
Yeah.
Give that guy like a battleax,
like a fucking 85 pound acts.
Who would do it in UFC?
Who would.
Who Do you think could win
and it's not saying that that the
greatest or the best,
but who could do that would have to be
the biggest guys who don't have to be
like the heavyweight champ.
There'd have to be steep meo chick or
Francis in Ghana or someone giant who'd
have to be a big powerful person because
you'd have to be able to swing that
fucking sword fast and you have to be
able to take a hit from a 500 pound cat.
You're probably gonna get fucked up
either way though.
You need one.
You may be able to take one good hit.
You're going to take one good hit my
just to feel like you're just going to
get fucked up.
Don't think you have a chance.
There's a lot of debates about this.
When I was reading it earlier,
of course people's,
a lot of people just as stupid as mean
Theo.
The line wouldn't have a good technique
so you can fuck it up.
It doesn't matter if it has good
technique.
The physical power of a lion,
it's just so overwhelming.
I don't.
I just don't think people understand how
much force it can generate,
how quickly it can move,
how quickly he could get you.
It'd be.
It would just fucking scramble on you
and it will be on you so fast.
Dude,
there's a video,
hilarious video of a bunch of dudes
running away.
One in comparison.
A leopard is 150 pounds or something
like that and these fucking people are
running left and right and this thing's
coming after them and you realize like,
oh my God,
like,
look at this,
this guy running.
Now watch the leper.
Take the corner.
Look,
just look at his slides.
The leopard is going so fast.
It's running on the walls on the top,
like the middle of the wall,
above his fucking head.
Watch.
How has he starts running forward and
the leopard comes into the picture?
The leopard is literally running on a
vertical wall,
like watch this.
Watch when it comes around the corner,
look at this.
It's running on the wall.
It's got so much power that it's running
on the side of the wall like you can't
even imagine the kind of physical speed
and strength that that thing has in its
body.
It's bouncing from the side of the wall
to the other side of the wall and just
trying to get some traction so we could
get ahold of your bitch ass way to get
ahold of your bitch ass.
You don't have a chance.
That thing that's a fraction of the size
of a lion.
Just a fraction.
Fuck man.
Oh Jesus Christ school.
Oh God.
This is a video game,
isn't it?
Look at it.
Climb over the top of that fence like it
ain't shit.
It's one of those video games on the
dark web.
I think
middle school leopard,
dude.
You find that thing.
You just get to shoot it.
You just got to shoot it.
There's not much you could do.
Oh,
it's fucking this dude up.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
oh my God.
Board
it.
Just bit them.
And then ran off.
He got lucky.
He got lucky that there was all those
other people and the commotion and 4
million people have watched that.
So would it.
So as,
as people were ready to see that 4
million people who have safely.
Why Shad and they're not crying at a
center right now or anything like that.
You have.
But watching that doesn't seem real.
You know,
we watched that.
If you were there in real life,
like if you're in the hockey rink,
sit in those excellent Goldstar seats
were in Mexico.
I think you're in China somewhere.
Yeah,
but they have been doing that in China.
Is this how I got the guy or not?
This one here.
Hold on.
Oh Wow.
Coming around here.
Try to climb the fence and.
Gotcha.
Wow.
Look at.
Dragged him down.
Oh my God.
What do you do?
It just wants to get out.
It doesn't know what it wants.
It doesn't know what the fuck it wants
to jump in.
The water didn't think they swim.
Swim.
Oh,
well that's not good.
I think he's bleeding or not.
Oh yeah.
He's getting his legs,
his arms,
his legs,
everything's getting torn up.
All that shit's on the ground.
That's blood.
It's his blood.
I don't want that on there.
We definitely don't want that.
I just think we really need to
understand when you talk,
you're talking about a large predatory
animals really need to understand what
bitches we are.
The toughest men that's ever lived is a
weak ass bitch compared to a leopard.
Just the fact that,
oh Jesus,
fuck man,
who's doing all this?
Oh,
I've seen this one.
This is in India,
right?
What happens in these areas,
man,
these cats,
they get into these villages and just
start fucking people up.
It's so crazy.
Imagine that as a small animal compared
to align in comparison.
Anything else you before we wrap this
bitch up and bring it home?
I think I've seen enough today.
Well,
you realize that,
uh,
if you're ever in a confrontation,
one of those animals,
that's going to be difficult.
Do you realize that you have that in
your mind now?
Yeah,
I think it's not a game as much as I
thought it was more of a game.
Well,
I think this,
I think it would be neat to go out and
hunt some type of an animal with a knife
to start to get my Garda hunt an animal
with a knife.
Do you think you could even have a
raccoon with a knife?
Yeah.
Do you think you could 150 percent,
do you think they recommend might fuck
you up though?
Fuck no man.
How quick do you think a raccoon moves?
Like if you don't get that first stab
into that,
that you do that double up.
How long do you think it takes for that
thing?
Is latched a hold of your face cloth on
your eyeballs,
out of your fucking head and you're
feeling your eyeballs getting socked out
of your skull because it tears through
your tissue paper.
Thin eyelids,
like they're nothing and it just biting
man.
Chewing your eyes out.
No,
I think if it got on,
you will do.
The tough part is if it gets on you,
you can't stab it because you'll stab
yourself.
This is Kevin rose is Kevin rose,
got a raccoon,
chucked it down the stairs.
Did he?
Yeah,
he fucked that.
Recognize the record was fucking his dog
up.
That's a guy who loves his dog.
He said he didn't even realize he was
doing it.
He was just doing it before he even knew
it was happening.
But look how he did it.
He hooked it like a,
like a pillow,
woof pitch.
Bam.
Damn.
We went after it.
Gangster.
I'd go out there with a gangster.
Yeah.
Well,
it's probably,
like you said,
it's just a natural instinct.
That's the basic instinct of a man,
you know.
Well,
what I was saying was with those guys
we're talking about when they
encountered that grizzly bear that you
just,
you reached this survival mode and you
have your regular operating system and
then there's survival default mode when
some real shit goes down like a fucking
grizzly bears right next to you.
Well,
I would hate that.
It will.
I think that,
you know,
going back to like what we were saying
earlier,
like that's the moment you'd find out
who you are and I would hate to find out
at that moment that I'm not a fighter,
you know,
well that,
that all could be built up,
right?
You can build that up through martial
arts that you like.
There's people that are just naturally
inclined to never quit and then there's
people that have to learn it,
but you can learn it.
Yeah.
I want to start learning some of it to
have just a little bit more that I'm
just to fill in whatever that space
inside of me and sometimes that feels a
bit inferior.
I don't
need to feel
invincible,
invincible.
No,
but I do.
I wouldn't mind getting a little call in
some of those areas where it's like,
okay,
if somebody grabs me like I,
I know that I'll be able to grab them
back.
Yeah,
man,
take Jujitsu.
It's easy.
You already know Eddie.
Yeah.
Why not,
man to fun?
Take some beginner classes.
Start slow.
It's fun to man.
You really enjoy it.
As long as you're a healthy guy,
like mentally,
like as far as your ego,
so long as you don't try to not tap.
Yeah.
No,
I don't need to.
When I.
I've just been.
I think I'd be happy to have the
comradery and that would be.
I think the tapping is probably some
humility.
That's probably good for you.
It is definitely.
It's just hard to do.
Especially when you're in the beginning
you'll try to resist and try to resist
an arm bar that maybe you should tap and
you can get hurt.
That's how you can get hurt.
You get hurt from not tapping.
Especially other beginners.
They don't know how hard like a black
belt,
you're more safe rolling with the black
belt and with anybody because they're.
They're going to be able to tap you if
they want to and when they do,
they're not going to hurt you.
Right.
Whereas you might get in there with some
Herculean white belt who's just learning
the techniques.
He grabs a hold of your arms,
like fucking yanks on it.
You're like,
ah,
you don't even have a chance to tap in
to and you're hurt.
Right?
Yeah.
That's a good point.
I think.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll see if Eddie can help me out
to get me.
He can.
Yeah.
He can do.
Last night was weird at the comedy
store,
wasn't it?
Did it was so weird.
They fourth of July as a strange night
to perform.
People like,
why are we here?
And they're like,
why are you here?
It was a weird crap.
It was a great crowd.
It looked good,
but they,
they.
They also felt odd that they were at a
show.
Yeah.
I didn't realize it until you said that.
You're like,
you're like,
yeah,
these people are thinking it's fourth of
July with the fuck.
It's not wrong.
It's not right,
but it's just like,
does my calendar even work?
The weirdest crowd you'll ever
experience as Christmas?
Yeah.
You ever do Christmas shows at the
store?
I did one Christmas show,
the store like 10 years ago.
I'm like,
well,
I'm taking the night off for the rest of
my life.
Fucking crowd's weird,
man.
They were weird.
It was more than 10 years ago because it
had to be like 2006.
You had fun though.
You haven't been feeling weird.
Oh,
last night.
Yeah,
last night was fun.
Last time.
It was fun.
Yeah,
I had a good time,
but it's just a,
it's a different feeling.
But I think people are feeling
differently about comedy now.
Uh,
because so many people are really
politically correct outside of comedy
and almost forced into it like you're
hearing so many things about people
getting fired from their jobs because of
sexual harassment or from a sexually
harassing joke.
Like someone would say jokes in the
office that were inappropriate.
So they got fired.
I mean this is happening left and right
here about the guy from Netflix that got
fired for doing.
Yeah.
He's having a conversation about
offensive words that you shouldn't be
using in comedy.
And because of this,
this conversation during this
conversation about
this subject,
he used the word Nigger,
right?
Because he was in this conversation and
did it one other time apparently because
of that.
Not Calling anybody that saying it out
loud was fired from Netflix.
That is crazy,
unless less,
if he was saying it like he likes having
a good time with,
right.
Like he was like,
you know,
right now,
like how was he saying?
Was He,
that's the thing.
Right.
But the thing is,
it's very strange that that word is only
for bitten by the people that can't.
It can't be used on,
you can't use the n word on you work,
but if you could use it on someone and
they happen to be a person of color than
that person,
you're not allowed to do that.
Right.
It's very interesting man.
Well I remember when I would go,
when I would ride my bike to school,
a lot of my black friends would get on
my bike,
you know,
and they get on and I would ride.
I mean it was fun,
you know,
and they used to call me the Nigga bus
whenever I rolled up and they would all
call me that and I honestly felt and
they were my friends.
It was fun.
So.
But you couldn't say it,
you know,
and I could,
I couldn't say it.
And also,
look,
I find,
you know,
when somebody says anything,
if it's something to do with,
uh,
race,
gender,
anything and they have malice or ill
intent and these days I think if you do
that,
somebody's going to correct you really
fucking quick.
And so I agree and in a bit,
but in a business setting,
man,
and that type of setting,
it's just,
yeah,
you,
you make people so aware that they
can't.
I don't know,
that's the fuck it is.
It is crazy.
But it's also,
he was talking about forbidden words and
comments.
It's his business,
but you're saying you can't make a sound
with his mouth.
This is what you're saying.
You're not,
he's not calling someone that name.
He's using that word and people file
complaints about him using that word.
So the people that he worked with ratted
him out.
He wasn't allowed to say the word right,
like,
but the car then,
then it gets real crazy.
Whereas if you're a black guy,
you could say it all day and it's funny,
you could say it in front of white
people and they can laugh,
right?
But they can't say it,
but they can't say they can't say it.
But if you're Chris Rock,
you can go up with the overall tonight
and just have like 15 different use of
that word in a half hour set and.
No.
And everyone's like,
that was great.
That was a great show.
Right?
But then,
yeah,
but then it'll be the same people that
say we should never say or hear this
word.
It's interesting.
Some people learn it from different
places,
some people learn it from black people,
some people learn it from white people.
It has a different feel,
a different meaning to it.
Well,
and I was even talking with Mr Peterson
the other day,
um,
who I was saying,
you know,
the toughest thing I find that,
especially coming from the area where I
came from were,
you know,
there was a lot of racism was probably
kind of went to,
it was popular when I was young,
but it was a part of the,
it was part of the,
of the cloth and the in the,
in the area,
you
know,
was poor,
black and poor white.
And you know,
poor people.
Like to fucking fight as you know,
it's crazy.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like,
hey,
let's be on the same team for a minute,
you know,
and we can change the love that you have
about white privilege.
Oh,
thanks man.
Hilarious bit.
But did you,
did you,
I find it fun talking to someone like
Peterson does.
Was it challenging?
It was challenging.
I felt nervous.
I felt nervous because,
you know,
I'm not as smart as him,
most people aren't.
Right.
But I also felt,
you know,
I know that um,
he really admired you.
He mentioned at the beginning.
So that made me feel a little bit more
comfortable because we had something in
common.
And then,
um,
and then,
uh,
he's a nice guy and I thought he is a.
I tried as much as I could to.
I wasn't trying to pick them apart or
anything.
I just wanted to see what he cared about
and he just genuinely,
I swear to God,
he genuinely,
maybe more than anyone I'd ever met.
He genuinely,
I think,
cares about trying to help young men
feel better for it and that,
you know,
we didn't get into anything political or
anything like that.
It was mostly about,
you know,
like a take a small step,
take a small step and you can change
your life.
Um,
you know,
if you have a,
if you have accurate goals,
evil,
he's a real clinical psychologist and he
understands the traps that the mind
leaves for itself.
Yeah.
And we all fall into those traps.
We all do.
Yeah.
And I've fallen into a lot of them and,
and,
you know,
so it was nice.
I mean,
I,
you know,
as I think of him as like a,
I thought a with Vera,
like,
you know,
like Chegg Rivera,
but like Canadian collect,
but I know he's not like,
I wanted to tell him that so bad and I
forgot,
but you know,
it was supposed to be a murderous
monster.
Right.
And he's not like that.
He's not a socialist like that.
But um,
but he,
you know,
he's like the,
he's kind of like the dad that a lot of
us didn't here and we need to hear again
and it's like we need those reminders of
some of those things.
And,
and I think he genuinely,
to me,
he genuinely wants humanity to be,
well,
that's what I felt from him does.
But the thing is,
when you want
men to feel better,
women will think you want them to feel
bad.
And this is the problem that we have
with this whole
right versus left male versus female.
Black versus white.
Anytime there's two groups and there's
supposedly pitted against each other,
anything positive for one side becomes
negative for the other side.
But I think it's the opposite.
I think that if men feel better,
they'll be nicer to women.
And I think that if they get their shit
together,
it's better for everybody.
And I think that if someone's looking
for men's,
like looking at men's values or men's
lives,
they're not disregarding women,
but what we look at it that way,
like,
no,
you should be paying attention to women.
You're obviously a misogynist.
You're focusing on men's rights,
like it's an insult to call someone an
Mra,
which is a men's rights activist.
It's kind of Hilarious,
you know,
like what is
like,
if someone was a women's rights
activist,
would you ever say that it would be an
insult to call someone a women's right
activist or advocate?
That's crazy,
but it's openly dismissed from the
feminine side,
making fun of the masculine side.
Like men's rights activists are openly
dismissed.
It's really,
it's very strange.
Yeah.
I like to think I'm,
you know,
I,
to me,
it's a lot of women's rights activists
and look,
the strongest,
hardest working man I've ever known was
my mother,
you know,
and I'll say that to the end of the
earth.
I mean,
my mother delivered newspapers since I
was born,
still does,
you know,
and um,
and she sacrificed a lot of raising her
children.
She wasn't there for us emotionally
because she had to work all the time.
You know,
she didn't even have,
she didn't have the opportunity to be.
But you want to talk about a feminist?
Like I'd never known one more in my
life.
I don't think,
you know,
uh,
she had to play a man and a woman,
you know,
in a lot,
in a lot of instances.
Um,
and I,
I,
that's great that you appreciate her.
Oh,
it to the end.
But that means so much to you.
Yeah.
And we started even like,
I started doing this thing where like we
try and treat a single mom out to like a
weekend when I'm at a,
on a,
on a weekend of shows,
you know,
pay for the sitter,
pay for the dinner,
you know,
and uh,
and not to object a single day as you
know,
but,
you know,
for me,
like I,
uh,
you know,
like I was even talking with Ms Dot
Peterson about this.
Like I never got to make like the reason
I think I got into comedy,
I never got to make my mom laugh,
you know,
like she was always,
she was always tired and he was always
working hard and tired and we just
didn't have that connection,
you know?
And so I think that's one of the reasons
I got into comedy.
The only person I've ever really
probably wanted to make laugh as my
mother,
you know,
and then here I am like just doing all
this other chicane re on the outside.
Does your mom think that you were
fondling when you were,
when you first started?
I don't know.
No,
I don't think he,
I don't think she thought if anything
like that.
My mom literally said to me,
I just don't think you're very funny.
Oh Mom,
dude.
I saw that yoga video,
the young video.
You're doing comedy with the longest
hair on the sides and stuff.
That was a little cutie dude.
That was the best.
And that was a really cool video.
I was probably like 24,
23,
maybe 23,
one,
two,
three,
somewhere in that range.
Man.
Crazy.
Um,
but I think,
uh,
I'd like to,
you know,
a lot of,
some of these,
you know,
aggressive sometimes angry feminists.
They're not mothers either.
And that's odd to me.
Like I'm,
you know,
people get,
they get into something because they
feel there's an imbalance and if it
isn't true feminism or they get into
being a men's rights activist,
I feel bad for those guys because I
think a lot of those guys are just been
fucked over by bad relationships or
shitty divorces are shitty laws in terms
of like a child custody and then they,
you know,
this is their,
their response and it's what we would
really like is for everyone to be
treated as an individual and,
and no groups,
no male versus female,
no fucking right versus left.
Just all human beings,
individuals.
And I think that's like the ultimate
goal for society,
for healthy society.
It's not to not eliminate judging
people,
but judge people based on their actions
and their words and their deeds,
not their sex or their,
you know.
But then you're always going to have
people that want to fuck the opposite
sex.
And you're always gonna have people that
want to fuck the same sex to make them
uncomfortable.
Like I've been hit on by dudes before
and been made to feel very
uncomfortable.
I'm sure you have to.
The only difference is a,
I know how to fight and when the dude
was hitting on me I was like,
listen,
cut the shit like this.
This wasn't a scene where I was worried
I was going to get raped.
It was.
I was worried I was going to go to jail
for fucking somebody up.
Like I don't want to have to hurt you
man,
but don't touch my dick again.
Like I've been in situations before,
but it was never a situation where it
was like a woman where I was worried I
was going to get held down.
Someone's going to do something,
but you can understand them when those
situations.
Like I can easily see how women feel
that way.
Like way worse.
Way Worse.
Yeah.
I get that too.
It's like I'll get like dick pics and
stuff from men into my instagrams and
stuff bro.
And it's fucking like,
some are aggressive with that shit,
but that's zero defects.
Zero.
Well you're going to get them right now.
They come.
People feel bad for Theo that were
withheld.
Puppies out.
Oops.
Something bold about a girl.
She'll send you a picture of her tits.
Those guys sends a picture of his Dick
is presumptuous.
Fuck like,
asshole.
Fuck you.
Fuck you with my.
Get a girls sending you something you're
excited to see.
Like if a girl sends you pictures of her
tests and she's holding them,
she was like,
I heard you wanted the.
You're like,
whoa.
Oh,
that was real.
This was crazy.
Yeah.
Gatorade.
Somebody gets those.
Look Open.
Sexually harassed by this woman.
Shot the fuck up.
You're fine.
Pussy.
Walk it off.
Dude.
I uh,
yeah.
It's uh,
it's so true that.
Um,
but I do know,
I start to notice how people feel.
I start to notice how.
Yeah.
When that happens.
Like,
oh,
I see how you feel.
I see now it's all women feel.
If they get that you get,
there's a door that you could look
through where you could see a mile away
maybe where this could go.
Right?
But to be the person that feels that
like a dude wants to stick his dick in
you and shoot loads into your body,
that's crazy.
It's like a video game
patient.
No memory go,
Mr.
that's,
you know,
that's the difference between men and
women and this is also why there's more
anger because women have experienced so
many guys trying to do that to them that
they developed this bad taste for men
and I understand that and we need to be
better men,
you know,
and I believe that honestly,
that's one of the reasons why,
you know,
I listen to your show.
It's one of the reasons why,
you know,
I'm,
I'm excited.
You know,
I was intrigued to listen to Mr Peterson
and reading his book and um,
you know,
I do want to be a better man and it's
hard to even be a better human being.
Everybody does it or a woman or what,
whoever you are,
we all want to do better.
And if you don't want to do better,
you're probably going to have a fucked
up life because then you're not trying.
You're not perfect.
It's no way you're perfect.
No one who's ever lived has been
perfect.
I ever want to pay.
Yeah.
And every day you have to pay attention.
Every day you got to pay attention to
everyday,
to your behavior.
To the way you think and you have to
constantly be assessing it and moving it
in the right direction and when you are
moving in a positive,
generous,
loving direction,
it feels better.
You feel better.
You feel like a better person.
Yeah.
You really.
You really do.
You know,
I'm glad that I'm.
Yeah,
I'm just glad to be alive and be able to
like try and like learn about shit.
It is exciting.
And you know,
I think one of the things that fucks
people up more than anything,
and this is what I've experienced this
with so many friends,
I'm like,
dude,
you're thinking about your past.
Like it's you and it's not you.
You can't beat yourself up for something
you did 20 years ago or the way you were
doing coke and fucking your life up five
years ago.
That's not you anymore.
Yeah.
You did do those things.
Yeah,
but that doesn't mean you are who you
are,
that you're,
you're not that person anymore.
Like as long as you decide,
but if you get caught in that trap,
you'll be that person again.
I mean there's,
we all know that one dude that can't
stop,
he can't stop.
He takes a few months off.
I'm sobering up now.
Everything's doing good and then whew.
Off to the races again.
Shows up.
Coked up drunk comes to the comedy
store,
won't shut the fuck up.
Shit.
Breadth and everybody's face.
Jesus sweat dripping off his ear lobes.
We all know that dude,
seven fingers in his ass.
We all know that dude.
There's so many of those dudes.
They just can't.
They,
they never break free.
They break free for a little while and
never go,
wow,
I don't want to be that person anymore.
They just go,
well,
I'm not that person this week.
And then,
you know,
they just get addicted to being sober
for a little while.
And then next thing you know,
just dark arts dark.
Why do you call it dark hard?
Just because if anything that I think
takes you out of like your path towards
some sort of enlightenment a little bit,
that's what I think,
you know,
dark arts,
they got in Harry Potter like voldemort
and everybody,
dirty spells turning candy into worms
and everything right
now.
Anything that takes you off of the path
of enlightenment,
the dark arts,
that's most things don't right.
Most Times you jerking off,
oh,
come on myself so many times bro.
Right,
and when you do,
do you ever feel good about it?
Do you ever feel like.
Yeah,
that's what I should times seasonal.
Like occasionally during the holidays,
Bro.
I'm not even joking.
Sometimes they're the holidays.
I'm just so filled with joy that the
shame doesn't get me.
Do you know that it actually does
alleviate anxiety and people recommend
doing it before you have a performance.
You have to perform in front of people.
Yeah.
It's not a bad idea.
WAC One off and your hotel room before
you go to a show,
you'd be like less anxious.
I could see that navy maybe for like a
special or something.
You know,
Vio von.
That was the three hours.
What is it really?
Wow.
More than three hours.
How long was it?
Three slash 20 jeeper.
20 time.
This conversation I've ever been on this
fucking room.
Dude.
Something happens in this place.
I don't even know how it works.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Feel Vaughn on twitter.
[inaudible] on instagram.
When you on the road next.
Um,
I'm actually going to be an ochsner
tonight through Saturday and then let me
try.
Yeah,
that's a great club.
Is it?
I've never been.
Oh,
you're gonna.
Love it.
It's great.
It's a sweet setup.
It's fucking awesome.
Crow.
Their pump that something's out there.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like a mini Bakersfield.
Oh Wow.
Closer.
I like that.
It's closer though.
I'm excited,
dude.
I'm like,
I'm going to try that Brazilian Jujitsu
and I'm like fucking knife.
Fight a raccoon.
Leave the recommends alone,
but get into that Jujitsu son.
Alright,
we'll be back next week.
You freaks.
Bye.
Thanks Cheryl.